so you're testifying
yes
i
you
is
and it's very hard i'm reminding myself
uh
i
thought
is
what is
um
thank you
oh sorry
yes
um
okay
open the hearing on house bill 1224
[Music]
prohibiting state and local governments
from adopting certain mandates in
response to covet 19
and prohibiting employers in places of
public accommodation from discriminating
on the base basis of vaccination status
as the principal sponsor representative
baldazzaro here to present his bill
is someone else
a co-sponsor prepared to present his
bill
okay the chair recognizes representative
leah cushman who is a co-sponsor
thank you mr chairman
um
i was not expecting to introduce this
bill so i very much apologize uh
so
uh the prime sponsor drafted this bill
to prohibit state or local government
agencies from requiring masks or other
facial coverings in response to cova-19
or other infectious diseases that's part
one of the bill
it amends 141c which is the um
infection communicable disease chapter
um basically not allowing mass mandates
of any kind
um
and
let's see
um also to prevent state or local
government agencies from issuing
immunity passports are similar
standardized documentation of cobit 19
vaccination status
basically
preventing any state or local
requirement to
prove
that you've been vaccinated for cova 19.
and also part three prohibiting
businesses from requiring documentation
of covid19 vaccination statuses so that
is the
part that applies to private businesses
and then
and that applies to
supplies to any
goods facilities advantages privileges
licensing educational opportunities
health care access or employment
and prevents employers from
refusing employers from refusing
employment to anyone
for failure to produce evidence of
coping 19 vaccination
and also
to prevent
discrimination from public accommodation
so that would be
any public-facing business
they can't keep people out based on
vaccination status
you think very well on your feet you
wouldn't ever happen to run into
emergencies uh as a nurse would you
sometimes
since you're a co-sponsor would you uh
take some questions yes
representative canarch
thank you very much you did a great job
for
hearing about having to do it 30 seconds
before you did it um but i do have a
question it comes down to what we've
already discussed in some of the other
bills
uh lines 20 uh 7-29
uh
have been superseded by the supreme
court ruling regarding the cms mandate
for uh
for health care facilities and obviously
this bill was written way back in
september long before we knew that was
going to come down
but would you agree that that part needs
to therefore be removed from this bill
because of the impact it will have upon
uh basically the closure of
almost all of our healthcare facilities
so i've actually been doing some
research on that and
um
i i've spoken with the 10th amendment
center and i also spoke with um
some people in florida where they passed
a bill um
that allowed for broad exemptions
um to employer mandate so an exemption
could be a potential amendment to change
this to an exemption clause that just
you know
provides a simple
exemption process whereas now when
people apply for a religious or medical
exemption they're kind of
being put through a arduous
process where they're
facing kind of a lot of
resistance and the employers are just
trying to tire them out and or turning
it into a religious inquisition
um so it would have essentially the same
effect at least someone who has a
conscientious objection or
is immune to covid that's that's kind of
how the florida law is written
um
but even if we were to pass like a
straight
um mandate ban like this bill proposes
um
the idea that the federal government
would you know
take the money from our hospitals is
i don't think that that would actually
that they would go that far
um
i think that it would come down to
how
um
how strongly the state
stands on its right to
legislate and have its laws
compared to a federal rule
you know i think that a state
a legislatively passed law would hold
more standing than a federal rule
may i follow up
uh if you when reading the supreme court
decision on that particular part the cms
mandate
they explicitly made the point that the
for
medicare medicaid that the federal
government is paying the bill well half
of medicaid got it they pay the bill and
therefore they have the right to
be able to place reasonable restrictions
for the use of the money that they're
giving because they're trying to protect
the patients
so do we have the authority to
contra man that or do we have does the
cms mandate
dictate how the exemptions work that
part i do not know it doesn't um
it only specifies that there are medical
and religious exemptions but in florida
they have other exemptions and they have
not had any issues
even since the court ruling
representative gay
thank you
madam chair
thank you leah um
would this bill have to have any kind of
amendment
to
do what uh florida has done which is
make the uh
request for exemptions less onerous
there would have to be amendment because
right now it just says um
that they may not so like it could be a
carve out just for the cms
but
even that is only theoretical because
technically florida's law goes against
what the cms regulations dictate and
they have not had any issue with cms
certification being revoked or
refusal to pay to pay by the federal
government and i think that
when it comes down to it that the
federal government is not going to close
our hospitals over this
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative cushman for taking my
question
would
you not you personally but would the
state be willing to financially support
the hospitals and defense in the event
that the federal government did in fact
stop sending the money to the state
would the state be willing to fund the
coffers
so that hospitals would not be in peril
to not be able to provide patient care
that is a good question of which i do
not know the answer
anyone else
with a question
i have one what about
um
a little mom and pop shop
where either mom or pop or both
are
getting a little older and have a few
health concerns and
they have three or four employees and
they just don't want to get sick
this bill would say
they will it will be illegal for them to
say you got to get
a vaccine
if you're going to keep working here is
that correct
uh that is correct
however under federal law already
no business can
deny
medical religious exemptions already um
if a
employee of a business with one in one
employer and one employee
and that one employee
submits a request for religious
accommodation or a request for
disability accommodation under federal
law they already have to grant it the
issue that we're having is not really
with the small businesses small
businesses
typically have been accommodating and
not turning it into a arduous process
for employees
really what we've seen a lot is the
larger corporate entities
who have teams of lawyers at their
disposal
writing their exemption policies to
sidestep that federal process for
exemption so really
the point is that no business can really
say that a hundred percent of their
employees need to be
vaccinated they can make the process for
exemption dif more difficult or less
difficult but
there is always that civil rights
act of 1964 exception
another question is under the religious
exemption i'm thinking back to
the time of the vietnam war when people
would
want to be conscientious objectors on
religious grounds and it's quite
understood that
people who were members of the historic
peace churches
if they raised a conscientious objection
that was quite easy because they
belonged to a so-called peace church
but somebody who did not belong to who
belonged to a different kind of church
and in fact had no difficulty with the
korean war or world war ii now just
didn't want to go to vietnam it was very
very difficult for the religious
exemption card to be played
is the drift in this bill
such that the religious
it is hoped that the religious exemption
is now much much broader
well this actually doesn't speak to
religious exemption at all it just says
that
anybody for any reason does not have to
be forced to take a vaccine
okay thank you representative weber
thanks i think i'll save it for the
exact session thank you
any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you
thank you for pinch-hitting
the chair recognizes
lori
who is representing herself and supports
the bill and wishes to speak for three
minutes
good morning my name is laurie ordolano
i live in nashua i didn't prepare
testimony because i didn't anticipate i
was going to speak but as i looked at
these bills i thought
i'd pitch in a little um i'm really a
person who enjoys choice and um
believe choice is very important and i'm
here in support of these bills because
the other choice it seems like there's a
lot of bills that go on the other side
i'm more opposed to than this
but i feel as though we're still
legislating too much from fear
from a space of fear and we're
we're
not recognizing
and gathering the kind of data and
looking at the type of data we should be
looking at in response to this
you know i've come a long way i masked
like a maniac
i had a mask on three weeks before mass
were called for because my husband ran a
company in china and what was going on
over there was um
so difficult and i was talking to a lot
of his chinese workers and you know they
were all about getting a mask on so mask
went on me when i was walking through
the market i was the only person wearing
one
and
you know i've come a long way in reading
and learning and studying and feeling as
though
that fear was not justified fully in the
beginning
and i think our data has always
supported that this is an a disease that
affected a segment of the pr population
most heavily the older people
but we reacted as if we needed a care
policy that treated people from zero to
a hundred
the same way
with the same regulations and
restrictions
and i think that's been a big error
i come from a city that closed the
public schools for 13 months longer than
anyone i believe in the state the impact
to our kids has been devastating
and our our teachers are pushing to
close again right now
this is enormously difficult for parents
and all the private schools in our area
are allowing choice
when the catholic school a half a mile
from me opened
i thought in the fall with choice
masking choice i thought they would have
a big problem
and and it seemed as though 80 90
percent of the parents were sending
their kids without masks it was high i
was shocked i said these schools are
going to close
they never did
they worked they came through it just
fine
the public schools with a full mask
policy had to close
for days
because of
elevated sickness
and teacher shortages that were you know
ridiculous
400 teachers out
i don't know why that's happening
but i know that choice is very important
to me
and my husband runs a a good-sized
company
with employees all over the world
and he never instituted a policy for his
employees because he had a lot of young
people the older people took the vaccine
the younger people didn't want to
and he didn't feel comfortable mandating
it because he really wasn't 100 percent
certain he understood the risks
his company came through it beautifully
and the younger people recovered quickly
they were forced to stay out the 10 days
they had an awesome remote system for
working so they maintained profitability
they had the highest profit
returns for the last two years than they
ever had he never thought he'd grow his
company the way he did because remote
remote working enhanced his business a
great deal and when his employees were
out they kept plugging
i mean the day coveted hit he set up a
remote workstation and he worked at 8-10
hour day that day
and he put all his employees on it he
never missed a day
um
[Music]
so i'm i'm very concerned about
you know these types of bills both ways
that push a one-size-fits-all protocol
for every segment of the population
i think data is starting to show us
particularly from europe
that we have probably made some mistakes
and we have a medical system that is
driven by profit unlike european
countries
we have to be very careful about this
and considering what we
you know what's going on here so i would
just urge a tremendous amount of caution
on this
and thoughtful deliberations in an open
mind
and no judgment
um you know no shaming
just uh recognize that we've all been
through a lot
and uh my opinions are very thoughtful
opinions i share with you and i and i
appreciate you giving me the time thank
you
thank you very much would you take any
questions from the committee certainly
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony thank you
the chair now recognizes paula minihan
new hampshire hospital association
has written testimony
she indicates she's coming to
oppose
the bill
mr good morning mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association we are
opposed to
house bill 220 fn
this legislation has a number of
sections
as has been outlined that related to
restrictions on towns or cities being
able to determine whether or not a mask
requirement will be imposed in that city
or town
restrictions on state government
entities being able to certify an
individual's covid vaccination status
prohibiting private businesses in the
state to require verification of their
vaccination status and prohibiting
discrimination on the basis of
covet 19 vaccination status
needless to say a very broad and
far-reaching bill a piece of legislation
we are opposed to the entire bill but we
focus
i will focus my comments today on the
sections that would impact our member
hospitals
as private employers
as i think a lot of you know the
hospital association and its member
hospitals announced in august of last
year a consensus statement in support of
requiring our health care workforce to
be vaccinated against covid in odor in
order to protect the health and safety
of our patients our staff and our
communities hospitals have announced
their own individual policies and have
been implementing them with robust
education for their staff
about the important benefits of vaccine
in doing so hospitals have sought to be
flexible and have complied
with all relevant state and federal
guidelines including offering medical
and religious exemptions
um the decision to require their
employees to be vaccinated against covid
was done to ensure the health and safety
of their patients their workforce and
their communities they have seen first
hand the devastation that covet 19 can
have on their patients especially those
that are unvaccinated
hospitals have an inherent
responsibility to protect the health and
safety of their patients who by their
very nature are very ill and the covid19
vaccine is the most effective way we can
we can do that requiring vaccines of
health care workers from communicable
diseases is not new for hospitals in new
hampshire hospitals have required
vaccinations against several
communicable and deadly diseases such as
mumps measles rubella chickenpox
diphtheria tetanus
pertussis and influenza as a condition
of employment with the same type of
medical and religious exempt exemptions
now allowed for under covert 19 vaccine
we believe it is absolutely the right
thing to do for the health and safety of
our patients our staff and the citizens
of new hampshire
furthermore to make such a vaccination
requirement and unlawful discriminatory
practice as stated in this legislation
would have a chilling effect on
employers in the state of new hampshire
not to mention an increase in lawsuits
as stated in the fiscal note the cost to
the state if this bill were were to be
passed is significant for all these
reasons we are opposed to house bill 224
and thank you for the opportunity to
share my views with you any questions
for ms minahan and thank you for coming
and sharing
representative lyon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for being here
again today
my question is there are other states
where hospitals have employees who are
vaccinated and covet positive working is
that something that new hospitals in new
hampshire would do
to allow coveted positive physician
healthcare practitioners to work in
order to fill the gaps
the hospitals have a workforce shortage
and a number of staff have been out due
to
coming down with kovid
breakthrough
cases and they have been
out because of that
as far as how long they have been out
before they're able to come back i
believe they're following the cdc
guidelines relative to that okay thank
you follow up yes yes thank you um and
as a follow-up if policy ever allows
covet active
coveted positive employees to work would
you loosen the backs would you be in
favor of loosening the vaccination
requirement if we are having healthcare
professionals who are coveted positive
working in our new hampshire hospitals
um i i can't really answer that
hypothetical question
thank you
by i will follow up on that by which you
mean you haven't thought it through or
you're not prepared to tell us
i
am have not thought that through so i do
not feel that i'm able to answer that
question at this time
thank you representative soloway
uh welcome back we missed you yesterday
thank you uh vice president minnie it's
always glad to see you nice to see you
were you aware
that one of the premier healthcare
institutions in this country
cleveland clinic
placed on
unpaid leave this morning
unvaccinated employees
i was not aware of that
that that is i have uh colleagues at
cleveland clinic where it comes from
um a quick follow-up thank you mr
chairman and
um
did you have any notice that some
organizations such as cleveland clinic
this is new today
have clamped down on a medical
exemptions for vaccination and are
basically not
allowing almost any of them
i can only speak to what my experience
is in new hampshire with our hospitals
and my understanding is from
not every single hospital has fully
implemented their policies but they have
been
my understanding is very
generous and and working with the
employees to try to work through
if they request a medical or a religious
exemption and the fact is that we have
about one percent of staff that actually
um
were affected if they did not um receive
an exemption um and were um
were
were not able to remain in in employment
you want to learn from you you're
welcome representative folsom
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking the question um can you please
describe um i know it's going to be kind
of a
a broad description but can you please
describe the typical uh process someone
has to go through
for a medical exemption or a religious
exemption for having um not taking the
vaccine there is a process there is a
committee um it varies by hospital these
are not
mandated
processes each each facility goes
through but again they've been as i as
my testimony indicated they have been
had these in place for influenza and
other required vaccinations for years so
there is a policy that the hospitals
have and an individual does go through
that process and there is a committee
that reviews those um and i think for
medical it's obviously a little
different than religious but again they
do have
those in place it is not one individual
making this decision
it is a committee yes to follow up um
thank you
i think um i probably didn't ask it very
well but what does the
employee have to provide to this
committee
during this process
do they have to have signs
slips from doctors do they have to show
their medical records do they have to
have something signed by their
pastor priest or or whatever i will need
to get back to you i don't know exactly
what they have to submit um i don't
believe medical records are necessary i
think there's a physician um at a
station
required
but as far as on the religious side i i
would need to get a little bit more
information for you which i'm happy to
thank you
any further questions for mrs minahan
representative gay
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my questions i actually have
three
okay the first one is
are the hospitals willing to accept the
liability
for employees when they suffer
adverse reactions
to the vaccines
the second question i'll let her answer
the first one please thank you
um there is a um
a law that was passed last year that
addresses that so um
i think that that
kind of speaks for itself
for those of us who don't remember what
that was even though we were part of it
i need to look it up to be honest i have
this year's bills in my head but i will
i will find it i claim exemption on the
basis of age
i'm right there i'm with i'm right there
with you i'm not so sure
representative gay number two please
when are you going to permit the usage
of old-time medicines that have been
proven
effective in over
160 trials
clinical trials worldwide
i don't believe i'm
capable or
qualified to answer that question
number three
what is the new hampshire association
policy
about people with natural immunity
as my i believe my testimony in um
various bills in front of this committee
um the hospitals support the
vaccinations um and again follow cdc
guidelines that say vaccinations even if
you have already had covid are
superior to
not being vaccinated
one more
what policy are you what studies are you
the decisions being made about people
having natural immunity as opposed to
simply having a vaccine i do understand
that currently the policy the
opinion is at least by some people that
having had covet and having natural
immunity and having a vaccine
is rated the best protection
but that's not what the hospitals
require
so are they going to adopt those similar
studies that say people who have a
natural immunity have superior
protection
than the people who have just vaccines
that is a question for our clinicians
that i would need to
talk with them about that question thank
you thank you representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you
many of you for taking my question
we have a long history in the state i
think also in this country you're trying
to allow business owners to run the
business they wait they think it should
be run
does this in fact in your opinion
infringe upon that right for the
business owner to run the business the
way they want to and enjoy the fruits of
their labor yes i agree with that
statement
representative representative leon thank
you mr chairman and thank you
i found the law that was passed last
year it provides liability for any
hospital who's operating and complying
with any
with any executive order agency order or
rule including but not limited to
waivers from cms
and the department of health and human
services
so as long as you're as long as the
hospitals are complying with any of
these rules their liability is protected
against vaccine injury against anything
else but it does not appear to limit the
liability for anything
if the hospitals are not following any
of those rules or guidelines do you
think that that's influencing the policy
and do you think that that is the state
dictating how the hospitals practice
their business no i do not
any other questions for ms manahan
saying none
thank you for your
testimony jay recognizes kate fry from
new futures
who also has written testimony to pass
around
good morning such a process now
my name is kate fry i'm the vice
president of advocacy at new futures
thank you for the opportunity to testify
on house bill 1224.
new futures um
it's a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all new hampshire residents
in this role we work extensively with
policy makers health care providers and
communities to improve the overall
public health and improve health equity
in the granite state new futures support
public health policy measures that
decrease illness and disease
as you've heard uh hb 1224 does a number
of things including prohibiting state or
local government agencies from requiring
mass or other facial coverings in
response
to covid it also prohibits businesses
from requiring documentation of covet
for vaccination status new hampshire
doesn't have either mandate at this
point
time and time again public health
experts have said that wearing mass and
widespread vaccination including both
booster shots is the best way to lessen
the impact of the coven 19 pandemic
based on that public health science and
advice for medical experts some
employers such as hospitals healthcare
organizations and nursing homes have
made decisions to mandate mass and
band-aids
vaccines for health and safety of their
employers and the individuals that they
serve
the freedom to make these decisions
should be left up to those entities
state government should not prevent
organizations from making choice based
on public health safety concerns
especially during a public health
pandemic businesses and health care
providers now more than ever need the
flexibility
and for the health of their employees
clients and patients so we asked the
committee to vote in expedient to
legislate i do have um written testimony
that i'll leave with you
thank you and while that's coming around
would you take some questions
representative kanark
just a quick when you mentioned um that
the difficulty of needing to be nimble
to sorry to be able to respond um
for the businesses but would you agree
that in general it is a bad policy to
place into statute
how public health officials will respond
because this applies not just to covet
19 but to other infectious diseases
could this be a problem if we face
something else and we're not able to
respond in an appropriate fashion
yes thank you for the question
representative i completely agree i did
work at the division of public health
services at some point in time and i do
know that you um things are ever
changing you have to be fluid so i would
agree with you that you need that
flexibility
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question um i appreciate that
you're trying to respect these rights of
these businesses
i'm curious if you know that there's a
certain point with corporations and
other businesses where because of how
they work with the state they're
actually trading off their own personal
risk and do you think that weighs into
whether or not they need to appreciate
the personal risk of their employees and
customers for that trade-off for
protection from the state thank you for
the question representative um
unfortunately i can't answer that
question i'm not um
knowledgeable in employees and risk i'm
sure there are a lot of people who are
but i appreciate the question thank you
representative
folsom
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question um we've heard how
hospitals often require other vaccines
up front
but if you are going to work at a
company
and they ask for
no other documentation of any other
vaccines
should they be allowed to force their
employees
to take this one
i think that is something that has to be
again up to the employer that's based on
flexibility i mean there is um the
representative connect said that there's
changing um policies and situations so i
i i really would leave that up to the
employer
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you so much
chair recognizes dr
j corson from manchester
who is in support of the bill doctor
please come
and what is your doctorate in
my doctorate is in chiropractic i'm a
chiropractic physician i'm a
new
new hampshire state resident i've moved
here from rhode island and uh to the
north thank you it's part of uh
my story is part of my testimony
actually
i didn't
plan on addressing some of these topics
but after having listened to some of the
other testimony i've been i
feel compelled to
add some things to my testimony
we just we just heard that uh
from previous testimonies that uh
because we we require these other
vaccines that we should you know it's
it's a
it should be a policy that we require
this covert 19 vaccine we shouldn't
question it because
of course we we require other vaccines
but i don't think those
testimonies take into account that
theirs the vaccine adverse event
reporting system now has registered
unprecedented amounts of side effects
and damages to people including deaths
that never happened with any of the
other vaccines and to call this
experimental medication that they're
a vaccine i think is unfair as well
because
this is not a vaccine in by definition
until they change the definition
this is really an experimental
medication that's really gone awry
um
we talk of i'd also like to talk about
the efficacy of this vaccine we're
finding out now that people who have
taken this vaccine have
a it's creating a negative
efficacy and i'd like to explain what
that means if you had the vaccine it's
damaged in the immune system
now people are more likely to contract
variants of this cova-19
virus or i shouldn't say cova-19 that is
a variant we should call it a sars covid
ii virus the new variants now we're more
likely
to uh
catch this virus if you've had the
vaccine so we're seeing negative
efficacy not positive efficacy in other
words we're not seeing a benefit to
these so i'd like to set the record
straight on that based upon the current
science
um we talked there was also talk about
natural immunity versus vaccine immunity
and
we are seeing now myself i
i had the coke the saurus covertube
virus with and most likely the delta
variant
and when i had my blood work taken not
only does my t cell t detect cell come
up positive which means i have
long-lasting immunity
not just the uh a short-term immunity
from the vaccine now we know because
boosters right there it isn't a
long-term
immunity it's a short-term immunity or
else we wouldn't require these boosters
but the natural immunity is far superior
as the evidence is beginning to
demonstrate
cloth masks
cdc has just changed their uh opinion
and you can and i think just this week
you'll see in all the major news
networks it's not just uh
a conspiracy theory conspiracy theories
are only conspiracy theories until
they're proven true and then they're
just a conspiracy but
the uh
the
cloth masks don't work
they just don't work this is a disease
that's spread by aerosols not by large
droplets
and then we may have an argument that
maybe
as physicians we should all be wearing
n95 mass and
i don't think that any i i would say
very few people in this room even know
what n95 means
n95 means the n stands for non-oil if it
gets wet it's an ineffective mask
if it's not fit properly it's
ineffective 95 means that it was
the mass are tested
for particles that are 0.3 microns or
larger it can stop 95 percent of those
but still the holes in that in that mask
are large enough to let
things
smaller than 0.3 microns through
like this virus the sars co2 virus which
is 0.1 microns
so
it's
this is an ineffective
way to stop a pandemic to put on these
masks
not my by my opinion but based upon the
science and then telling people to put
on a cloth mask when we know that an n95
and we've had this virus now for two
years over two years don't you think
that the scientists who just who did the
experiments to to show that an n95 mass
could stop point three
things that are 0.3 microns or larger 95
don't you think in two years we could
have done a study to show
what effectiveness what percentage not
a 0.1 micron
virus would be for that mask
it will be something less than 95 but
perhaps it's a it's an n30 mask when it
comes to a virus this this particular
virus only 30 percent effective
and then if we put it tell people to put
a mask on a cloth mask or even these n95
masks which we know now are not 95
percent effective because the the
particle the viruses
is 0.1 microns aren't we putting people
in harm's way thinking that they're
protecting themselves
when actually they're putting themselves
in harm's way the the the part of the
population that's most at risk
you're telling them
sew a mask together made out of your
underwear put it over your face a piece
of cloth
and you're going to protect yourself
from virus no what we just did was we
put them in harm's way
this wasn't initially part of my
testimony but i thought i should address
those topics i'd like to now
address
parts 1 and part 4 of this bill which is
requiring the mass and discrimination i
sit here before you today because i had
to flee the state of rhode island
because if i continued to practice
even though i had natural immunity and i
was able to prove it in my serology in
my blood tests and my my antibodies were
four times higher
typically than those people who had who
were vaccinated
even though i could do that
and i went to seminary school at trinity
college of the bible before i went to
chiropractic school and every one of
these vaccines was either tested
its efficacy
or developed
using aborted fetal cells murdered
children's cells
and i couldn't put that sin into my arm
but the state of rhode island didn't
allow for a religious
objection so
i had to leave a half a million dollar
practice with 11 500 patients that i
took care of
it was worthless when i went to go sell
it the practice the people that evaluate
practices told me it was worthless just
sell your building and leave and that's
exactly what we did we sold the building
we sold our home and here we are
and i don't want to see that happen in
this state which is why i'm becoming
active
in
in politics i never thought i'd be a
politic be in politics but here i sit
right
so requiring mass and discrimination on
the basis of kova 19
is the reason why i sit here before you
in the state of new hampshire
trying to keep this to live free and die
state
to keep liberty in a place
of democracy in a democratic republic
i'd like to now address
so if you want to see what what you know
if physicians will leave with health
care providers what they can how they're
going to respond when they're forced
you're looking at it before you go on to
that point you'd ask me five minutes and
i'm going to you you've gone past that
i'm going to ask you now to summarize
because we've got a number of people who
wish to speak
i understand
immunity passports and and requiring uh
documentation
80 years ago in germany we were asked
where are your papers
i would it would be an absolute shame
to walk into a place of business
and be asked to be shown your papers
particularly because my the heritage of
my family
goes back to to germany and russia
and i will not allow
people walking into a place of business
to be asked show me zip papers
so much to summarize
this bill on all four parts protects the
freedom of new hampshire the people of
new hampshire it protects their health
and it protects the livelihood of the
people who live here
i thank you for your time would you take
any questions from the committee i would
be glad to any questions
do you have any written testimony
this is the first time i've ever been in
a state-built state house building so no
i didn't know to prepare a written test
you don't have to
yes i do
do we have one
okay and the chair recognizes uh
representative folsom if um there are
several people that would like some of
the information that you shared um and
the description and the definition of
the masks
would you please
write up what you talked about today
and any other thoughts that you have
that you weren't able to finish
and send them in
if you need help on how to do that we
would be glad to do that during the
break
that would be great i'll be glad to do
that for you thank you thank you so much
for coming in my regards to dr palmer
thank you very much
i'm sure i'm sure he he's not rolling
over his graves
because of your comment thank you
chair recognizes um pam
uh
the napoli i cannot read this but
i said enough close enough and
help me get it right you got it right
wow
thank you
my name is pam dinapoli and i am the
current
executive director of the new hampshire
nurses association and i'm a nurse
um i submitted my uh written testimony
digitally and so i'll just summarize a
few things
right now
you've heard the narrative over the last
couple weeks about vaccines and mass and
mandates and opposing and support so i'm
just gonna talk about two key points
um we still have a pandemic the pandemic
is still raging um you're hearing about
fewer
cases being hospitalized but that
doesn't mean that they're being
discharged from hospitalization
so the the beds are still at capacity so
we're concerned about that
and further restricting the use of
proven interventions such as
vaccinations masking and social
distancing including staying home when
you're sick to decrease the spread of
covet will prolong the pandemic and
result in a continuing strain on health
care resources both human resources and
capacity resources
and it will continue the spread of
preventable illness and death
the osha general duty standard says it
requires employers to provide a work
environment that is free from recognized
hazards that are causing or likely to
cause death or serious physical harm
by prohibiting employers in places of
public accommodation from adopting
mandates that would otherwise protect
employees from transmission of covert 19
has the potential to cause death and
serious physical harm to vulnerable
populations requiring such protections
including those unvaccinated
at the end of the day
we all want employees and those that
they serve to be treated fairly that
means equal protection provided by some
mandates the recent support supreme
court ruling
continues vaccine mandates for health
care workers which is the right thing to
do
further protections that pro that
private employers can implement has the
potential to stem the trickle-down
transmission effect as a result of
individuals objecting to practice best
evidence policies
if everyone is to be treated fairly then
everyone must do their part
discrimination discrimination on the
basis of vaccination status is a two-way
street the choice to be unvaccinated in
the workplace per cdc guidelines
discriminates against vulnerable and
immunocompromised
and this is not the right thing to do
for the public's health
the new hampshire nurses association
urges you to oppose hb 1224 continue to
allow employers and educational
institutions the right to establish
requirements for their own employees to
practice protect the health and safety
of those same individuals
and all who utilize their services
thank you in advance
any questions
representative acton
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
would you um agree that there should be
a different
standard for
medical
facilities and with private employers
for instance say truck drivers who are
in the
in the vehicle themselves all day long
who are now being barred from going into
canada
or or
other workplaces where
there may be some exposure but nothing
like a health care facility where
uh people are are in close contact all
day with people who have cope and so
forth would you agree that there there
should be a a separate standard for
those two bodies
well i think it all depends on your work
environment and where you work so if i'm
a truck driver and i'm in my cab and i
get out and i pump gas
and i go in and i pay for the gas and
that person in the in the store that
doesn't have a mask is not vaccinated
comes into contact and then it trickles
down so that's that's the way viruses
work is that the more exposure the more
the virus expands so i think everyone
needs to be protected the level of
protection so if i'm a healthcare worker
i want full ppe
when i'm taking care of a patient if i'm
a truck driver i may just want to wear a
mask when i go into the store so in
terms of a standard
it definitely is leveled but everyone
should be protected
thank you
representative leon thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question
it seems that you're very knowledgeable
about this so i'm hoping i can ask you a
more detailed question
are you
do you know of any studies that show
that the mass protest protects anybody
other than the wearer outside of a
health care setting
i couldn't quote you a study but i've
read studies yes
if you could forward those to me i've
evaluated them before i'd appreciate
that
thank you
and follow up
and follow up would be
are you aware that even with the vaccine
people are able to transmit covet so
that it does not stop it in its tracks
and the main benefit is to reduce
hospitalizations which is another
personal benefit right
thank you
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question thank you for being
here today and isn't the reduction of
hospitalizations a benefit not only to
people who
are not hospitalized with covet but also
a benefit to everybody who has a car
accident a heart attack a stroke
cancer surgery
that currently needs hospital of space
but is not able to get it that's exactly
right
or the person who has pain in their
elbow and is putting off getting their
elbow surgery so that they're not able
to exercise i mean the capacity issue is
more than just not enough beds for
covered patients it's not enough beds
for people to protect their own health
or get the treatment that they need
thank you
representative delemus
had your hand up
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
as we heard from the doctor prior
considering the evidence i mean
well first of all do you believe
that new information
as we continue to examine this disease
should be considered when establishing
mandates and usurping people's freedoms
well i think that answers your own
question as we continue to get evidence
everything's going to evolve so we need
to start at the place of the most
protection and as the evidence becomes
more clear then we change is like what
we have seen with this virus so far so i
think that we all have to continue to be
knowledgeable and read the evidence and
stay protected especially those who are
vulnerable or being taken care of
because of their vulnerabilities follow
up thank you
thank you
um and considering the evidence i
believe it or not i used to sell filters
and um
so the some of the filtration
systems that i dealt with actually
were very effective because they used a
static electricity to capture particles
and the microns that the doctor was
referring to
very important and if
if he is correct and i believe he is
that the size of the of the virus itself
is a 0.1 micron which is actually rather
large
um
turn it into a question
well would you believe
that well considering the evidence
how how effective do you really believe
the masks are
if they're allowing particles to get
through if they're only filtering to
you know like a 0.3 and the microns 0.1
you're getting you're able to pass
aerosol through the masks in and out and
aren't the masks uh
originally designed
to protect the wearer and
not the person who the wearer is
speaking to
well personally i'll continue to wear a
mask until i have evidence that i don't
need to
thank you
given the
change in protocols that we
first recently heard from sweden and
then denmark and then the united kingdom
a couple days ago
do you believe that evidence is coming
i think so i mean i think the scientists
are definitely working on it
would you believe there's at least two
variables as to
why one is science is ever evolving
as new information happens and secondly
it seems that the pandemic is evolving
from
the original one to delta to omicron to
i guess son of omicron
there are more greek letters but
apparently this is just a variant of the
variant so
given would you do you know that given
this
evolution of both scientific knowledge
and
events
we shouldn't be surprised that
we will be given different
suggestions regarding masks
don't ask me to repeat that
i i think that that
if we've learned anything from this
disease is that it's evolving and that
we have to continue to look at the
evidence and i guess continue to try to
prevent
preventable illness and death
thank you any other questions
representative gay one question
representative i'll choose
thank you
um are you have you studied the clinical
trials
of hydroxychloroquine
ivermectin
and in particular the study in
argentina of 800 health care workers who
were divided into
a placebo group and the group that got
ivermectin but it was double-blind so
they didn't know what they got
are you aware that the 400 of the 200
people who got the placebo
got sick 58 of them got sick and of the
600 who got the ivermectin
none of them got sick
it was prophylactic
uh i've read a lot of the armor mectin
studies yes and i know a lot of them
have been discredited so what we want to
look at is the meta-analyses which looks
at all of the data together because 800
is a small studies we put all the data
together into what they call a
meta-analyses and 15 percent of the data
in the largest meta-analysis study was
discredited so again i'm remembering
like masks is something that we're going
to continue to look at
but not use okay we strike we're
straying from the uh bill here
um
please keep your questions on the bill
iver mechton is not on the bill
uh representative
um
cofold
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so we're we're often called upon to um
to balance the rights of one group or
party against the rights of another
and um you know one example would be a
lot of people have a concern that
they don't want to be offended by
certain speech and we have to balance
that against the constitutional right to
free speech
so i guess my question is you know
do you acknowledge that there are
two competing sets of rights here one is
the right to medical self-determination
and then the other is
i would not call it a right but your
perceived right or what i think is is a
right that you're perceiving
to
to live in
a germ-free environment or as safe safe
as possible environment
uh as i understand this bill it
prohibits mandates so
that
means that i don't have the right to
then
mandate something for the protection of
my own
employees so i think yes everything is
balancing but the idea to prohibit
mandates
doesn't give us the flexibility that we
need
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
chair recognizes mark rossetti who
supports the bill
cody folks
good morning
my name is mark rosetti and i'm just a
regular guy from the street
uh i do a lot of study on this
and with regards to this mandate even
this word mandate
i don't find it in the state
constitution
and i don't find it in the federal
i find mandates are despicable
this is a republic
it is about the individual
we don't need a nanny state federal
government
telling everybody
that they're here their herd immunity
or their own immunity is no good
and teaching
everybody nationwide and around the
world
that their immunity means nothing
unless we want to keep on jabbing you
with a
needle the choice of the people has been
taken away
i've got a very close relative or had a
very close relative
he was a school teacher in massachusetts
he ran in the marathons never a smoker a
drink or a party it worked out every day
believed in this covert thing and went
and got the vaccine
three days later he was dead
it's a little too much to take
i know many people that have lost their
jobs over this
you've got to choose whether you're
going to put a needle in your arm
or keep your job i know several in new
hampshire
that's wrong that's not right when
anybody does anything that's wrong
against you
that's an abuse of your rights
for thousands of years we've had herd
immunity
who ever thought of telling people they
didn't have a choice about what to do
ever
this is my body
you want to give me a shot you better do
it with lead because you're not doing it
with a needle
ever
there's been no fda
approval
of the covert vaccines that we've gotten
until just
last week
there's been no study of a year two
years three years five years or ten
years
and we're ready to mandate people and
tell them show me your papers
and then we really need to look at
what's in the vaccines
has anybody here ever heard of graphene
oxide
besides
baby fetal parts being in these vaccines
which has been proven
graphene oxide is in every one of these
vaccines
graphene oxide gets in your system
and it creates like its own little
wiring system
and 5g can be used to control it
study it
the cdc
has been proven time after time
to be full of lies
and you know early care
i got the cobra real bad the beginning
of last year
and i had ivermectin in my cabinet
i couldn't breathe the second day i was
ready to go to the hospital
the doctor said no no no don't show up
what's going on well if you've got that
we don't want you bringing it here
that was that was cmc in manchester new
hampshire i won't say the doctor's name
early care worked for me i had
ivermectin at home
so let's go over these uh the things in
this bill
prohibit state or local government
agencies from requiring masks
i don't need any
government telling me whether i should
wear a mask or not i said that before
if you want to if you want to put a
fence up in your yard
to cause mosquitoes from not crossing
your fence it's the same thing
as wearing these masks
you can't put a fence up with holes that
big in it and expect me mosquitoes not
to get through it's the same thing
secondly people that are getting these
shots are the ones that are losing their
hurt immunity and they're shedding to
other people
and giving other people the virus
that's a proven fact now
but back to back to this law prohibits
um
state and government agencies from
issuing immunity passports or
standardized documentation
this government we have especially the
federal one cares not about the states
we have 50 states
and there would be no federal government
if we didn't have those 50 states
so they're turning around now and it's
just like when they do the uh
when they come to your house and do the
census mr rossetti uh we've got a lot of
people testifying i'm almost done i
appreciate that thank you sir okay
uh when they do the census they collect
a lot of information
for a long time people in
state governments have been against the
government collecting that information
when they when they document you on this
they put you into a bank and they have
all your medical information as far as i
know socialists love having the medical
system in their hands
and finally
somebody said it before me show your
papers
i'm not showing papers to anybody
whether i have a vaccine or not is
nobody else's business hipaa law covers
that
and i don't think any state
anywhere should be mandating that people
have to have a vaccine or lose their job
or can come into this public place or
restaurant
that is totally against the freedom that
america was built upon
if anybody's got questions i'll gladly
take them
i know i'm a little scary looking but i
won't harm anybody
the only thing the only thing that's
scary sir is i envy your head of hair
any
questions have a question i i
while i certainly understand
it's my business if i get sick
what about the idea that
if i'm a carrier
other people get sick because of me and
i have a responsibility to them unless i
choose to live way up north in the woods
and never have contact with anybody else
there was a question in there i forget
whatever it was but what do you think
about that
well if you're sick you shouldn't be
going near other people
if we if we look at the r naught factor
okay the r naught factor is on
every every you get the measles the
mumps this that or the other they've all
got an are not factor
the r knot factor for covert is 2.4
for the measles
it's 18.
so when a kid has the needles measles we
don't shut down the street
we don't tell everybody you can't go
near joe's house because joe's sons got
the measles
in other words if you're sick
protect others put a mask on
but don't make me have to wear a mask
because you're a
a jerk
so
that you know i'm just like i said i'm
just a straight guy from the street but
come on here we got to get serious this
comes down to common sense the proof is
turning around now when england turns
around and says
stop this with the covet and the backs
and all this stuff
and many other countries are doing this
when we look at india
and five percent of the populations got
covered you've answered you've answered
my question we gotta
answer my question
one question from representative canark
thank you um i was curious uh
that
you made a comment about the
the constitution earlier and that there
are no mandates stated in the
constitution but are you familiar with
the fact that in part one article three
the new hampshire constitution
that it says when men enter into a state
of society they surrender up some of
their natural rights to that society in
order to ensure the protection of others
this is a bit of a follow-on to our
chairs question
so would you agree that there is
recognition in the new hampshire state
constitution that we do not have
complete liberty but we have to give up
some for the protection of others
well yeah this is this is why we have
resolutions instead of mandates
this is why we suggest to people to use
their common sense if you're sick we're
a mask don't go out in public don't be
kissing and hugging everybody if you're
not don't
so to mandate something is a government
putting down an edict
that causes wars
one follow-up
do we not mandate that you cannot drink
excessively and then go out and drive
for the protection of others
well there you go there's the common
sense thing if i'm gonna go out and
drink excessively
and get in a vehicle and be blacked out
and run as others over that's my fault
that's that's on me it's also against
the law
well it is against the law i agree with
you 100
but does i don't see the word mandate
and the alcohol was
thank you mr rossetti
thank you very much excuse me there was
a hand up before i said that so
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and discussing all of these i know that
our constitution does talk about those
trade-offs but do you
knowing that even if you're vaccinated
you can still spread covid do you think
that forcing someone to be vaccinated to
protect others when those who are
vaccinated can be carriers would fall
under that requirement
i don't think anybody should be forced
at all
at all i think that should be suggested
to them i think that's up to the the uh
patient doctor relationship
and and if and i'm not going to go into
it but doctors have been bought off
and all you have to do is study it to
find out they make a certain amount of
money for a covered case certain amount
of money for where it is a certain
amount of money for us whereas that's
what okay
sorry you answered my question i really
appreciate that you've answered the
questions thank you so much okay thank
you very much
and
now
the troika of abby rogers and marie
marconi and making her very first
appearance
as a
you're a 3l are you i am in turn janice
emery
and it was suggested we'd be nice to her
because this is her first time and i say
this is what our committee excels in as
being nice
so welcome thank you
good morning members of the committee
chairman pearson my name is abby rogers
i'm joined today by
janice emery the extern our extern from
unh law and
anne marie mccary who's the section
chief from
the division of public health services
sorry division of public health services
um
uh we are here today to express our
concerns serious concerns and opposition
to hb 1224 and we won't repeat what
others have said before us would would
like to comment on the bill and make
some
points about our areas of concern so i'm
going to turn the mic over to anne marie
mccary
[Music]
good morning chairman pearson and
members of the committee for the record
my name is anne marie mccary i'm the
immunization section chief of the
department of health and human services
division of public health i'll be
providing some information on some of
the more concerning parts of house bill
1224.
hb 1224 as written does not clearly
define places of public accommodation
it's unclear if hb 1224 would apply to
nursing homes hospitals or any other
medical facility where coveted
vaccination requirements exist
the americans with disabilities acts
define a public accommodation as a
private entity that owns operates leases
or leases to a place of public
accommodation places of public
accommodation include a wide range of
entities such as restaurants hotels
theaters doctors offices pharmacies
retail stores museums libraries
amusement parks private schools and day
care centers while the department does
not at this time have any intention of
implementing schools or child care
requirements for cova thank you so much
while the department does not have at
this time any intention of implementing
school or child care requirements for
covet 19 vaccination the department is
concerned that hb 1224 would circumvent
the department's authority under 141 c
20 a
to implement future immunization
requirements
there is too much uncertainty about
covet 19 to place a prohibition that
would threaten the ability to make
future public health decisions
such as those for school and child care
entry
hb 1224 seeks to prohibit a state
governmental agency from issuing a
vaccine passport or standardized
documentation for the purposes of
certifying an individual's covet 19
status to a third party or share any
individual's vaccination record or
similar health information
the department is obligated to issue
vaccine records to individuals who were
vaccinated at state-run clinics where
the department served as the medical
provider
the department also opposes 1224 as its
contrary to 141.c which obligates the
department to allow authorized users
such as primary care physicians nurses
schools and the child care agencies to
access the information in the new
hampshire immunization information
system
the department is also obligated to
issue immunization records to
individuals who have their information
entered into the nhiis
records can be attained through written
request or downloaded through the secure
patient portal this bill would prevent
patients from accessing replacement
immunization cards or electronic
versions of their information
the department is also opposed to hb
1224 as the language as written is
inconsistent with 141-c
paragraphs two and three which state the
exemptions where proof of code
vaccination may be required
thank you very much for the opportunity
to testify today
hi janice emery extern with dhhs um we
just wanted to add that the department's
goal here is really to balance public
health with individual choice and we're
happy to take any questions you've done
this before
i have not sir
wow
thank you i i have a question for
whomever wishes to try to answer it
you mentioned
and i i think i've got this right
that this bill would
do something negative
to the department's
authority
is it not the case you have the
authority we choose to give you
that you work for us you are the
executive
folks to do
what the legislature
either instructs you to do or not do
what we prohibit you to do and your
authority is derivative is that not
correct
thank you for the question chairman
pearson um that is correct um one for
rsa 141c was put into statute to protect
public health and protect against
communicable disease so as
according to the statute that's our task
and if the legislature chooses to make
amendments to 141c we would have to
abide by that that's correct
i think that's a kind of a scary truth
but i just wanted to nail it down yes
that's correct representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here today
as the token attorney on the committee i
welcome you
um
my question is
would enacting this statute
repeal your authority to provide me with
a replacement card for the volunt for
the vaccine that i accepted voluntarily
at a state vaccine site
when i lose the card
and it would prohibit
my ability
at my choice
to share my decisions appropriately with
whomever i chose to share it with
if i happen to lose the little piece of
cardboard that's currently in my purse
[Music]
thank you very much for your question
we are concerned that this bill would
potentially impact that ability to issue
the cards
as this bill does
state that prohibits state or local
government agencies from issuing
passports or similar standardized
documentation of covert 19 vaccination
status
thank you let me follow up on that
question if that means i choose
to travel
to another state
where they have chosen and i'm not in
their legislature they have chosen to
require me to present a card
i'm over a barrel now and i'm even
frantically now searching to see if i
still have my card
would that not put me at a disadvantage
and take away my choice to travel
if a state uh yes thank you for the
question if a state required
proof of vaccination to enter the state
and you did not have a car that you
would
be over a barrel
yep i did find my card but thank you for
the answer any other questions
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you very
much
um
would a couple of word changes in that
paragraph number roman numeral one where
it says they don't issue
the passport
uh
i'm i'm guessing and please tell me what
you think i'm guessing that the attempt
in this paragraph is to say
that you don't issue passports but it
doesn't prohibit you issuing proof
because the real issue here i think and
you please tell me what you think is
that they're trying to
ban passports that would be a
requirement to go somewhere that's to me
is a different issue there's two issues
here i think thank you for the question
representative gay i would um i would
point you to page two paragraph two
where there's a definition of um in the
legislation of immunity passport well it
does say uh means vaccine passport
vaccine pass or any standard
documentation standard documentation
would refer to the card that the
cdc card that the state distributes uh
proof of vaccination that this the
department does not
issue any sort of vaccine passport
thank you
any other questions
anybody want to throw a nice softball to
the new kid in town
what kind of law do you hope to practice
i'm currently working on my health law
and policy certificate so i'm hoping to
do something in that area of law thank
you so we're going to get to know you
that's the goal okay
thank you so much thanks for coming
and with that
i close the hearing
on
house bill
1224.
and
we'll take about a five minute break to
collect our thoughts before we move on
to 1604
i would like to take credit i had
nothing to do
little to
down here
yes
[Music]
okay
dennis acton to the front
how do you do
there's more
okay
can i just look
in many ways
right
[Music]
but you're up at five o'clock every day
i slept last night
i don't think we've done
oh
is
[Music]
wow
my words
thank you very much yes
how are you doing so you've got a new
team approach to all of this
the team approach
so you're the dirty kid
that's going
okay
unbelievably helpful
all right thank you
um i do not have the names written down
all i knew is that you were going to do
something and then people just started
okay um i guess i didn't catch that i
thought it was just one of those
thank you
okay
[Music]
can i have that list
oh good you do
i i miss the fact that it was an actual
subcommittee so i didn't
catch that and write it in
okay
tuesday
um
14.95
number
okay
is being rewritten
okay but it's not an early bill even
though it has a fiscal note
okay
yes these bills here i added this one
[Music]
not me
um
you put down uh 1662 was an early bill
that's the i.t security
bill
again
okay so 1662 is an early bill then
okay
is
right it goes on to the consent calendar
or the first yeah
that's it we don't have to worry about
it going to a second committee or
anything it's done
well as long as
as long as it doesn't get pulled off
consent and
but i don't think that's gonna happen
at this point
yesterday's coffee
you know what's amazing
that chair is really low isn't it open
the hearing on house bill
1604 fn including
state medical facilities
in the statute providing medical freedom
in
immunizations
and our own
representative cushman as principal or
prime sponsor
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee um
i'll just state it anyway my name is
representative leah cushman and i serve
on this committee um also a registered
nurse and
i bring you this bill hb
fn um
this bill
goes back into
hb 220 that was passed
and signed into law last legislative
session and just repeals an exception
for freedom in in immunizations
for state health
care facilities
there was an exception that was added i
believe during the committee of
conference and
the bill as we passed it out of this
committee did not have that exception
and so i'm just hoping to
remove that and
basically
i don't believe that private employers
should be able to hold livelihood over
employees heads for having their immune
systems
unadulterated
and on top of that we have a healthcare
workforce shortage
and you may have heard a lobbyist from
the association of counties tell us that
they only lost 10 nurses in the county
nursing homes
and i have heard from
far more than 10 that had a very
difficult time either securing an
exemption
or just
chose not to fight and just left
so
i i will say that i see the county
nursing home shifts
being an agency nurse and they are
constantly running short and
[Music]
you know
they had a shortage before and
increasing that shortage even by 10
nurses has a significant impact
everywhere is hurting for staff but
especially our county nursing homes um
they don't pay as well to begin with um
you know 10 nurses is a lot you know one
unit is typically run by one or two
nurses and you do the math
um
you know and the my understanding though
um is that you know we have exemptions
but the process
has become very cumbersome and to speak
uh to representative folsom's question
um there are questions for religious
exemption such as
uh
have you received any vaccines before
what makes this vaccine different
can you describe
how your religious beliefs impact
other aspects of your life
um
sometimes
they're almost set up the questions to
be like a trap
to kind of
you know
guess
just to make it very difficult for you
to
prove your sincerity in your belief
um
so at the end of the day though who
suffers the most from losing staff
it's the patients
and the remaining staff when you're
running short staffed you have
you know a significant increase in
workload we already have you know high
workload as nurses and lnas and
mnas and um
i think
just that the state needs to not condone
this kind of treatment of people
we should be setting the standard it's
unethical to deny skilled competent
medical professionals employment and to
deny patients and residents the staff
needed to care for them
based on their vaccination status we
have ppe
there are other ways to mitigate
this and now as the is
you know uh
evolving as mr chairman said at the last
meeting
uh last hearing
you know we understand that it's not 100
protective
and it's actually only about 43 percent
and those who get vaccinated can still
have the virus and there are
nursing homes in new hampshire that are
permitting
positively
tested
nurses and other staff to work
but they're not permitting unvaccinated
staff to work
um
so
you know
it just comes down to in in health care
we have the right of bodily autonomy
it's it's the nurses job to ensure
self-determination for patients
and
i think that that self-determination
needs to be protected for everybody
including health care workers they don't
give that up just because they want to
help people and care for people they
still have
you know their body to worry about and
their health to consider and their
beliefs and their conscience and
there is moral distress when they're
faced with
these decisions and moral distress is
one of the leading reasons that
healthcare workers leave the field
so um
the uk just changed their practices
um and they are removing mandates for
healthcare workers
and maybe last year they felt that it
was
um
you know prudent but now where it's
being shown that even if you get
vaccinated you can still get it and
transmit it and that omicron doesn't
really respond to the vaccines as well
as delta and alpha did
um you know they've they've changed
course in their decision making and
will be repealing requirements for
health care workers and they also noted
that part of that decision
had to do with staff shortages
so i think new hampshire
should make the move to remove this
exemption from the medical freedom of
in immunizations act
and
allow
our state to hire nurses
and other health care workers to work in
our facilities regardless of whether
they've received a vaccine or not
representative canark
thank you very much and unfortunately i
have to ask the same question to ask you
on the last bill and that is
what do you perceive will be the
implications given the supreme court
decision that the cms ruling regarding
the requirement for vaccination for
health care workers
is constitutional
and our county nursing homes are funded
primarily by medicare and medicaid
what do you perceive will be the problem
when we violate that bypassing this and
how will we
plug
the loss of revenue whether you think
we're going to increase the taxes that
immensely in the state to pay for our
health care
thank you for the question um
so as i stated during the last hearing
and i i know that this is a new hearing
so um in speaking with the 10th
amendment center and with legislators in
florida who passed legislation that also
contradicts what the
cms rule is they have they foresee no
issues with the federal government
continuing to certify and
reimburse for medicare and medicaid
services
follow-up follow-up
since that supreme court decision was
handed down less than three weeks ago
would you not say that that's not been a
sufficient time to find out what's going
to really happen with that
um yeah i suppose that you know there
could be a movement by the federal
government
against the state of florida
so far it doesn't seem like it's going
to be an issue and again the 10th
amendment center
took took the position that you know the
state
has more legal authority
in a legislatively passed law
and more legal standing than a federal
rule and that the federal government
will
work with us and will not
you know withhold
important funding for our hospitals and
other health care facilities
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um and i hope you mr chairman that you
will indulge me a little bit as i
meander towards my question here
that would go completely against
everything we always do
thank you for not making me an exception
um
representative are you familiar with the
glencliff home
i am not representative okay so the
glencliff home is
a new hampshire
run
nursing care facility for people with
severe mental illness it's an unusual
situation most states do not have those
but in new hampshire along with new
hampshire hospital
new hampshire the state of new hampshire
also runs the glen cliff home which is
up where representative folsom lives
in the white mountain in the
very western part of the white mountains
um
so my brother-in-law lived at the
glencliff home for maybe eight to ten
years until he passed away a year ago
he
was severely mentally ill his whole
adult life
um
very smart guy very funny guy great
athlete when he was young
but he had this terrible illness
and it led to terrible consequences with
his physical health and so he ended up
he needed the care of a nursing a
psychiatric nursing home and he lived
there for 10 years where they gave him
fantastic care
just as one example of the people who
live there my brother-in-law um
would not have been able to socially
distance or wear a mask consistently
because he was
paranoid and had all different kinds of
things going on in his head that um
even if he had wanted to do those things
i don't think he could have done those
things so my point being is that he's an
example of the type of very very
vulnerable people both medically and
psychiatrically who live at the
glencliff home
the glencliff home is one of the
[Music]
institutions
that is included
in this aspect of the bill that you
would suggest repealing or
changing the um
exception
um
i know from
your testimony
and from previous testimony that um
you don't think the vaccinations are
that effective or as effective as
some other people think they are but um
you did say that they were 43 percent
effective in terms of something so i
know that you agree that they are
somewhat effective for some things
so my question is
don't you think
people
who are severely psychiatrically
and medically impaired and can't really
take care of themselves
um
deserve the
deserve the the
highest level of protection from the
people who work with them that they
could possibly have
thank you for the question
representative and yes of course i do
believe that they should have
protection um
insofar as it doesn't violate the rights
of others
right so
currently we have the ability to rapid
test for covid
you know and the idea that
a vaccinated person is guaranteed to be
protected
has been shown to be false i mean we
could have someone who
is vaccinated but
you know is morbidly obese and has other
compounding health issues and they may
not have any protection if they have a
poor immune system to begin with a
healthy
young unvaccinated person may be less
likely to be infected and
contagious than than that vaccinated
person so
there are so many variabilities in
how effective
a covid vaccine can be in an individual
i don't think that it justifies a
blanket
requirement
for healthcare professionals to be
vaccinated in these settings and again
we still
always have the federal
civil rights act of 1964
and
you know no facilities
um
you know can guarantee a 100 vaccination
rate because we do have
medical and religious exemptions
but i think what the state of new
hampshire needs to do
and the reason that i want
to bring this bill forward is i think we
need to step forward and say
we believe in the rights of the people
to choose when it comes to this vaccine
and that includes our health care
professionals
representative folsom
thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh this
is you may have the answer to this i'm
hoping you do um
you mentioned rapid tests and that the
unvaccinated come in and they could have
a rapid test done every time they came
to work
knowing the number of breakout
infections among people who have been
vaccinated do you know is it standard
practice to also do a rapid test every
day on
people who are vaccinated
it depends on the facility so different
facilities have
have taken different approaches to that
some require three times a week for
everybody
some require
daily just for unvaccinated some don't
require testing at all
so it depends on the facility and and uh
there have been different approaches
taken
thank you
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question i know that the
supreme court ruling has been stated as
if it's all said and done but are you
aware that they just
granted a they stayed the preliminary
injunction pending the disposition of
the government's appeal in the eighth
circuit and depending on what happens in
the eighth circuit this will or will not
be upheld so some we don't know the
ultimate disposition of this case yet
i heard
some mumblings
that something was going on with it but
i did not hear the detail so thank you
thank you
representative woods thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
you mentioned the chilling effect on
hiring
staff
for nursing home
if the mandate is in place
would you believe that there are staff
who
will not work because
the other staff is not
vaccinated in other words uh
i i know this uh personally
a nurse has decided to withdraw
from a nursing home
because
of a if if there is no
mandate in place
she will feel unprotected
and therefore she has
family who have heart transplant and she
just can't take that kind of risk so
there's a chilling effect on the other
side too
that if there isn't sufficient
vaccination
that there will be nurses leaving as
well do you have any idea how
big that component would be um thank you
for the question i don't know how big
that component would be
um but i do know that i have a list of a
thousand he'll over a thousand health
care workers who have reached out to me
um
for help with dealing with mandates
because they have been forced to leave
their jobs and overwhelmingly that's
been
the report from health care workers that
i've received
however um even if this didn't pass
again that employee can never be
guaranteed a 100
vaccinated work environment and that
includes patients you know we can't
force patients to be vaccinated
and
you know
it calls into question um i guess
you know i i would never
deny treatment to a patient based on
their vaccination status and i and i
just hope that
that that nurse wouldn't either
representative gay
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
setting aside the question of personal
rights which of course is important but
we're we're really concerned i'm
assuming that all of us are very
concerned about protecting patients
and so
do you think
that we have far superior ways to
protect patients
such as the staff using prophylactic
treatments such as with hydroxychloric
and
and ivermectin which have been proven to
protect people from getting sick
thank you for the question so there
haven't been any um you know clinical
trials comparing the efficacy of
vaccination for prophylaxis versus
hydroxychloroquine or ivermectin or a
protocol of those so i can't say
that one is more effective than the
other but i can say that there are
studies showing that ivermectin
and hydroxychloroquine as part of
preventive protocols are do have some
efficacy in preventing covid
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
mr cushman's taking my question as i
look through the bill
and look at line three i may have missed
this new testimony
it says
medical freedom from immunizations are
we talking about all immunizations
including things to do with hepatitis c
things to do with
flu is a good example i mean there's
many immunizations beyond covet and i
think the broad
breadth of this language is concerning
because there's many times in which
vaccinations and other capacities have
been shown to be very effective and also
very important to the safety of the
patients in which the facility is
treating i think
i want to give clarification on what you
mean by immunizations
sure thank you for the question so the
statute that
this
um
this is repealing language from
is specific to cova-19 vaccination
yes follow-up
would it be possible then to uh instead
of saying immunization be specific it
says covet
so it actually just repeals
so there's no language that's going to
be inserted it's repealing
um
it's section 2e
which
basically says that
would you read it exactly yes
so paragraph 2e
says apply to county nursing homes the
new hampshire state hospital or any
medical facility a provider operated by
the state of new hampshire any political
subdivision identified in paragraph one
it's saying that paragraph one shall not
apply to those and paragraph one says
every person has the natural essential
and inherent right to bodily integrity
free from any threat or compulsion by
government to accept an immunization
accordingly no person may be compelled
to receive an immunization for cobit 19
in order to secure receive or access any
public facility any public benefit or
any public service from the state of new
hampshire
or political subdivisions thereof
representative merchant thank you mr
chairman also representative cushman um
i misread the mill so i stand corrected
on what i was trying to say so
i now understand it thank you thank you
for clarifying everyone
anyone
else representative snow
and your microphone friend
thank you
why do i have to fight with these things
all the time
i'm sorry maybe this is all clarified in
141c but this bill only seems to
reference staff
not residents or patients in any
facility is that the intention of the
bill or is it
is it is the intention of the bill to
only apply to staff because there's
nothing in the bill that clarifies that
so
it doesn't specify and
as it's written now in statute it also
doesn't specify it but the bill i mean
i'm sorry the statute that it's
in
talks about public benefit or public
service
for um
that are offered from the state of new
hampshire so my assumption is that
right now
the state of new hampshire's nursing
homes and
other medical facilities are not
prohibited from requiring
patients
to be vaccinated
while this language is there
and when we repeal it
they will not be able to deny a public
service or benefit to patients or
employees
of state
medical facilities so in your mind it
does apply
excuse me
yes so in your mind it does apply to
both
patients and staff
even though it isn't specified
correct and is there any useful reason
why it should be specified
no i thought she said no i would like it
to apply to staff and patients that they
should have medical freedom in
immunizations thank you
any other questions for the
representative
saying none thank you and the chair
recognizes james monahan from the new
hampshire association of counties
thank you mr chairman i'm jim monahan
with the dupont group and along with
kate horrigan
we represent the new hampshire
association of counties
um i'm here today on behalf of the
association in opposition to house bills
6 um
1604.
um as the sponsor bill indicated uh this
is a piece of legislation which would
make changes to um house bill
220 which passed just a few months ago
um
that
bill
created the exemptions for a number of
facilities including the county nursing
homes and it's primarily on behalf of
the the county nursing homes that we
were opposed to 1604
and hope to work with the committee to
ensure that the exemption
from state law as it applies to the
county nursing home stays in place
as you all know as members of your
county delegations the county there are
11 county nursing homes in new hampshire
they care for approximately 2 000
residents
and employ approximately 4 000 staff at
the county nursing homes um among our
problems as articulated in the letter
that we sent you today is that the
challenge associated with conflicting
federal and state
regulations on the nursing homes um the
um i think
the committee is very well versed in the
provision the cms provisions for that
requires a rather rigid
infection control including vaccinations
at the at the nursing homes including
county nursing homes as a requirement
for
reimbursement through
medicaid
that's the cms rule that we've talked
about our concern with eliminating the
exemptions exist today
is that would put us in conflict uh with
that which raises a whole number of
problems including which has been
identified here which is potentially
putting
um
the medicaid match
for the county nursing homes at risk
we have
heard people suggest don't worry about
it
there's some organization in the state
of florida that are saying it's probably
not going to be a problem but in fact we
think it probably will be a problem uh
both in its uh actual execution as well
as the financial steps that that that
the county governments would have to
take if those funds were at risk um you
know i
we're talking a bit a minute about how
we're going to gather some other
information for the committee but i
think one of the risks to be concerned
about is whether or not there's a risk
of those funds being um not
presented to the county governments
whether that would become an event on a
gas fee that would require
some sort of a notification of it being
a financial event which would put county
revenues at risk um that would happen
well before
any sort of a denial of the match from
the centers for medicare and medicare
medicaid services
um
so um as and i should also add that uh
prior to the the cms rule uh and the um
in the supreme court decision a recent
supreme court decision uh uh
house bill 220
uh was enacted in such a fashion that it
created the exemption for the nursing
home for the for the county-owned
nursing homes and so while a lot has
evolved between now and then
it's a lot of work for the staffs at the
nursing homes to comply
with the federal regulations and adding
another potential
interference with that with state
statutes becomes rather problematic for
the counties
i should also say you know we've
kate and i have a weekly conversation
with the county nursing home
administrators and
we want to be as accurate as we possibly
can with the committee with regard to
the impact on employment
and so
when we meet this week i'm going to try
to gather some additional information
but as the committee is probably well
aware
the cms guidelines uh have a
uh phase one and a phase two component
of it and they're also
uh it has it's a
relatively it's a relatively new
um provision so particularly after we
were waiting for the supreme court to
act
um a couple of counties couple of larger
counties actually went ahead and adopted
a
um
a more rigid vaccine i want to be
careful not to call it a mandate because
as we well know there are medical and
other exemptions under the guidelines
but a number of at least two if not more
counties move forward with the exemption
prior to the
the go live dates from the cms rule
but those go live dates uh would be
february fourth as we as we're
interpreting them would be february 14th
uh for the uh for the first
vaccine and then the second
dose would be on march 15th so it's
still an evolving situation for the
counties but what we do want to do is be
able to report back to you after we meet
with folks this thursday more accurately
what some of the numbers are with regard
to folks that have
had their employment terminated as a
consequence with non-conformance with
the guidelines
and then one of the more challenging
things to do would be get our arms
around whether or not folks have moved
on because of the mandate we'll do our
best on that
but i think it was observed by someone
in this side of the room that
what we'll miss in that part of the
conversation we'll try to gather for you
is how is the
vaccine guidelines at a county nursing
home helped with employee retention and
that may well be because it has reduced
the incidences of people calling out
because of
being sick or people that want to work
in a safer environment
that's not as easy a number to gather
for you but i think it's part of the
consideration for the committee um we're
going to try and do that
so um i mr chairman i trust you're
probably not going to act on this bill
before thursday
um
but um
okay thanks um but i'll tr uh kate and i
will try to get information through the
committee through you mr chairman with
regard to some accuracy on the numbers
but i think the numbers that kate
reported to you last week uh seem very
consistent uh with what we're hearing
from the
county nursing homes particularly
knowing that we have some live
experience uh with two large nursing
homes that implemented
the guidelines back in november december
time period so
um so anyway with that i'm happy to
answer any questions the committee may
have i'll answer
one of yours we won't be executing
on thursday but we must by next tuesday
it's an early bill thank you
representative weber
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i just needed a clarification
because i was trying to
make sure i understood
which dates or which implementations
related to the two larger
nursing homes in new hampshire and which
were the cmc guidelines am i right and
thinking it's
february 14th and march 15th are the cmc
guidelines for implementation cms
guidelines
okay so kate's
kate's my fact checker on that but she's
here yes okay and and
so
the nursing homes that you referenced
actually
implemented those guidelines earlier and
they've been in place for some time
since since the end of last year is that
correct
um
they implemented a
set of vaccine guidelines if they i'm
not sure if they're exactly the same
as the cms guidelines but they are
has been represented to us essentially
the same
and when did they implement those uh i
can check on you for that but i think it
was in the november time period okay
thank you
representative cofolt
thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
you mentioned data collection and that
you're going to be looking at the
benefits of
having everybody vaccinated in terms of
employee morale and employee retention
and the ability to hire new employees
will that data also include information
about employees that have
have been lost because
they don't want to get
don't want to be subject to a vaccine
mandate uh yeah that's as i said that's
the number we'll try to collect for you
to be honest it will be as
as concise as we possibly can but if
somebody
moved on to other employment and their
exit interview didn't include
information about vaccine their
hesitancy around the mandate uh we
wouldn't know that so well we'll do our
best to give you a sense of it um you
know
it's not a scientific data collection
that's underway
follow-up um
thank you and and
do you have any data with respect to the
rates of covid infection
among staff including among staff who
are vaccinated versus non-vaccinated
staff
uh we might
if i can gather that information i'll
do my best to get it to you and then i
think the other piece of it is they they
try to determine and i don't know how
well
they can do determine if it was
community spread um or more likely from
the facility
more
um
are you aware of any
county nursing homes in new hampshire
segregating
employees and
patients
based on their vaccination status that
is having non-vaccinated employees
working only with patients
with certain populations of patients
and
vaccinated employees working with other
vaccinated patients are you aware of any
situation like that yeah we were there
were situations of that last fall
when there was some pretty aggressive
outbreaks in some of the more rural
county nursing homes where uh they they
did just that they created a reward and
made some accommodations around that but
that was prior to the availability of
the vaccines um so i don't know if that
continues um but again i will try to get
an answer few in that
mice i suspect that those provisions
that
because
the vast majority of the the staff are
complying with the guidelines that the
necessity of that um
has
they've moved beyond the necessity for
that
thank you representative leon thank you
mr chairman and thank you for taking the
question
i i know that the healthcare worker
shortage is not just in new hampshire
and is around the country and i'm sure
you've heard that some states are
allowing vaccinated employees who test
positive to continue working through
without a quarantine period
i would like to know if any of our
county nursing homes are doing that
policy or if they are considering that
policy because if they do i'd like to
understand
where they stand on that versus
unvaccinated employees
this is going to be a long meeting on
thursday with the nursing administrators
but yeah i don't know the answer to that
i can try to get an answer for you but i
should say
part of the concern we have with
1604 is that by eliminating exemption it
creates a rather rigid um policy in that
we i think we all know we've heard from
all sides of the debate this is it
continues to be an evolving situation
there are periods where there needs to
be more stringency and others with
perhaps in the future we might not need
them
there's different guidelines around
isolation quarantine and things like
that and the problem with
this bill in that environment is it
takes that flexibility away from the
nursing homes
from the professional staffs there
if you've talked to your county nursing
homes and the administrators and the
directors of nursing you know they put a
lot of work into
infection control
they have to comply with standards that
cms sets that are
followed on by surveys that take place
at nursing homes and
not having the flexibility to operate
your facility in a way that complies
with infection control and takes into
account the safety of staff and
residences is something that
that that flexibility and that ability
of your nursing administrators to keep
their
their environment their residents and
staff safe is a problem
with this type of state government
mandate on a local facility
follow-up
it sounds to me like the reimbursement
guidelines from cms are actually having
more of an impact on day-to-day onto on
the practice of our county nursing homes
than our county commissioners are would
that be a true statement
um
or at least on these policies the
vaccine policies well with regard to
the
federal medicaid reimbursement of course
you know that's all dictated by the
social security act and cms rules and
regulations that the you know
unfortunately that or fortunately
depending how okay the county
commissioners and u.s delegation members
um uh are not in a position to
um uh to formally make changes to
one more
and i'm i'm not sure if you're aware
that they simply stayed the injunction
that supreme court hasn't rolled down
finally
if they end up overturning this rule and
that that cms had this authority will
people who have been vaccinated be able
to unvaccinate themselves once the
policy changes
i'm not sure if that's a county
commissioner decision or i'm trying to
be following the supreme court
i'm not familiar with the procedures for
um unvaccination
you'd make a lot of money if you did
mr monahan i don't know if you know
that
my job as part of the county delegation
in rockingham county is overseeing the
nursing home
and further that i had a loved one in
there for quite some time so i'm very
close to the situation and
my uh
therefore my thought was
if we
did our job well and interviewed well
and hired well
and the person is evidencing that
in this case he
is keeping up with an ever-changing
focus would i not be encouraged to let
our rockingham county
nursing home administrator under the
watchful eye of yours truly and a few
others get on with his job
with the flexibility he needs
uh
yes i believe that
yes i believe that and i appreciate the
approach representative thank you sir uh
representative weber
and following on to that question would
you also agree that
it's very important to recognize that a
nursing home
serving manchester and a nursing home
serving coast county may have very
differing needs at varying times
and that those needs may change
as we have seen them fluctuate
astronomically during the course of this
particular scourge
yes i believe that and that you know
would contribute to the reason why we're
opposed to house bill 1604
any further questions of mr monahan
thank you very much sir and we will be
looking forward to hearing what happened
on thursday before next tuesday
thank you
joseph christie and ellen lapointe from
dhhs
they have handouts or there is a handout
they oppose the bill
good morning chairman and members of the
committee my name is joe curisti i'm the
chief financial officer and legislative
liaison for new hampshire hospital and
glencliff home and with me today is
ellen lapointe the chief operating
officer for new hampshire hospital
we are here to testify in opposition
today against house bill 1604
and our
written testimony
i'll just briefly touch on a few of the
key points of our concerns
so the first of which
as we understand the first sentence of
the medical freedoms act uh 220.
it does not limit specifically to covet
19 and so we do believe that house bill
1604 would inhibit our ability to
require other forms of vaccination
as a condition of employment and that is
a fairly long-standing practice in the
medical community for things like
rubella
measles etc
and so that is that is one of our
primary
concerns relative to
the cms coven 19 vaccine mandate
as as it currently stands it is our uh
understanding and we've reviewed this
with the attorney general's office that
it is active
and so we are working towards adhering
to it
the enforcement mechanism that cms has
indicated for the kovid19 vaccine
mandate for hospitals is through the
accreditation process so these surveyors
and accreditors for hospitals and
nursing homes uh bear the primary
responsibility for enforcement and what
that really does is
it it creates challenges for healthcare
facilities if they were to not be in
compliance with the mandate
there's a progressive disciplinary
process from an accreditation
perspective that could put our
accreditation at risk
and that is a significant concern of
ours for a variety of reasons so
without accreditation a lot of our
operations and clinical workflows
will be subject to a lot less regulation
there is also the concern that
very few facilities are unaccredited and
there are a lot of healthcare workers
who would likely not want to work in an
unaccredited facility so we do have some
concern relative to the potential
turnover if we were to be put into that
situation again that would be a
progressive process
you know cms has indicated they want to
work with organizations at every effort
to try to come into compliance with the
mandate but that is uh how we have uh
interpreted the guidance that we have
received up to this point
um and then our last uh i would say
significant point of concern is relative
to
the loss of uh cms related revenues
should we not be able to comply with the
cova 19 vaccine mandate so um we did
provide some fish fiscal information
relative to what that could
mean for new hampshire hospital and
glencliff home
in thinking about that particular
situation further
since we provided that financial
information
commercial insurance revenues may also
be at risk for healthcare facilities as
a lot of them require accreditation as a
part of the contracting process
so that that also is a concern of ours
and we are
uh
we anticipate that that risk could
ultimately result in something like new
hampshire hospital and glencliff home
having to be 100 general funded
um so the relatively significant risk
there for uh for our organizations um
and the last point i also um
sort of wanted to thank representative
shapiro for his comments relative to uh
glencliff home and the populations that
our two organizations
serve it is a very challenging
population to work with from a infection
control perspective and we certainly
feel we have an increased obligation to
do everything we can to protect those
individuals
especially the ones who are within our
facilities
on an involuntary basis so with that we
would be happy to answer any questions
that you may have and thank you for the
opportunity to speak
merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking my question i'm
going back to my confusion before
i think i'm more confused than i was
i thought i read the bill correctly i'm
not sure if i'm reading it but if i go
back and look at the actual medical
freedom
immunization 141c one hey sort of
brought this up
it says on the first line every person
has the natural essential
an inherent right to bodily integrity
freedom from any threat or compulsion by
government to accept any
aid back sorry immunization
so the way it's worded and it goes on
and talks about
covet is there confusion some confused
between that word immunization versus
the next line it talks about covert
specifically
so in repealing this so we talk about
the potential to repeal repeal all
vaccinations because of the way that's
worded in the statute therefore i may go
back to my original thing about being
confused i'm now definitely confused
um thank you for the question i think
that
is certainly the concern that we are
raising as an agency today is that first
sentence does not include any of the
words coving 19 or anything to that
effect and therefore
repealing our exemption from the medical
freedoms act
could potentially inhibit our ability to
require other forms of vaccination for
employment
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you um
are you aware that the attorney general
has already ruled on the scope of this
legislation um the the law that's
already passed and that he has ruled
that that's been ruled that it only
applies to covet 19 and not to other
immunizations i was not aware of that
thank you
you're welcome
representative weber
i was going to ask is if if perhaps the
ambiguity in that statute is not a
lesson to us as
as a committee when we look at bills to
make sure that a statement of purpose
clause is labeled as a statement of
purpose clause and then the actual
statute
becomes the actual statute
i think the
but we would certainly agree with some
additional clarity
thank you so much appreciate your
testimony of course thank you very much
chair recognizes lori
orlano
i think i got it yesterday is it the
same today yes good
okay um i'm going to be brief because
it's lunchtime and i'm absolutely
certain everyone's hungry
so
um
i'm going to set my stop watch my name
is lori ordolano i'm from nashua i don't
have written testimony but i just wanted
to make a few comments on this i'm a
citizen i don't represent any medical
community or have a medical background
you know all of this type of legislation
is driven by these immunization issues
by the devastation of this
illness and the death toll that it has
taken and the burden it's placed on
hospitals but i can't help but start to
question whether our treatment protocols
were really appropriate in addressing
this and i think we have to
consider that when we look at this type
of legislation i mean this is an
inflammatory disease and treating
inflammation is something we've known
how to do for years and years and years
and i'm starting to wonder why we didn't
know how to do that for this one
i'm very concerned about data reporting
you know i don't think we have great
data reporting going on and i think we
need to do a better job with our data
reporting so we can make decisions on
these impacts and one of the gentlemen
here who spoke about you know people
potentially in nursing homes that are
going to quit because they don't want to
be around people staff members who are
unvaccinated very legitimate point but
we need to have a sense of
how many people that encompasses versus
the ones who are just trying to maintain
employment while having vaccine choice
i'm very concerned that just because we
say the same thing over and over again
doesn't make it right you know
capitalism drives our our system and
those with the most money can also can
often dictate the message and from that
message we can have a false sense of
security and be misled so we have to
question more carefully what we're being
told and as a citizen you just have to
try and peel away at what you think is
the right thing to do i'm also very
concerned about in this only recently
happened for me the natural immunity
issue i was living in a bubble for a
while because i actually didn't realize
that people who had coveted and were
employed in jobs still had to go be
vaccinated i i didn't think that was
true when i first heard it i grew up or
when i had my children one of my doctors
had always said natural immunity is much
better than um immunization because of
the way it goes through the nasal
passages the eyes and mouth that it was
better than a muscle injection i just
always thought that that was true
i was aware of it
and then all of a sudden
natural immunity didn't count anymore
and i've only for two months gone to our
board of health meetings in nashua i've
attended four and i've asked our doctors
two two actual doctors a pediatrician
and a pulmonologist and a dentist sit on
that board and i ask them why we don't
consider it anymore and they won't
answer that question they just won't
respond so anytime
i ask a question
and i try to speak to them after the
meeting because you know public comment
isn't about questions it's only about
comment and that's fine because that's
what rsa 91a allows you no problem but
informal discussions after to connect
with them i i can't get answers to those
questions and if i can't get answers it
raises um concerns with me that we're
not looking at data appropriate
appropriately and you know life comes
with risks it just does there's no
guarantees and i am very concerned that
the younger population is being forced
into something that isn't suitable for
the younger population because we don't
have enough data
you know i get it for the older
population i really do but
these costs and the money and the money
we're not going to get from the federal
government maybe we need to think about
the potential risks and costs associated
with forcing something that we don't
have a lot of history on and the impact
of the cost of that to our state
um when we do these things i just i'm
just concerned so
i've i've done my almost four minutes so
i'm stopping
wow thank you
thank you
does anybody wish to ask her a question
sing none thank you so much have a good
lunch
and then the final pink card from the
new hampshire nurses association pan
thank you for test taking my testimony
on this bill as well
i just want to preempt my statements by
saying i was notified during my um
testimony that my digital
testimony did not get to you and
some of my members said the same so
we'll be emailing it to you after this
meeting
um the second was i just want to echo
the comments that our understanding was
that this applied to all of the
immunizations so in reading my comments
we're really talking about the term
immunization and again what was said is
hoping that that might be clarified
anyway in in 2021 the medical freedom
and immunization act became law
in signing the medical freedom bill
governor sununu's press team announced
as long as
as long as he has said governor sununu
believes that private entities have the
choice to require vaccination brandon
pratt the governor's deputy
communications director told abc news in
a statement the simple fact remains that
the safest thing one can do is get
vaccinated as soon as possible to help
increase the state's already high
vaccination rates
by the nature of the business it was
logical then and now the county nursing
homes new hampshire hospital and state
operated medical facilities were exempt
from rules of the bill
being cared for by providers who have
not been fully immunized as defined in
cdc's annual guidelines which include
vaccines such as hepatitis b
influenza pneumococcal pneumonia measles
mumps and rubella among other vaccine
preventable diseases puts these most
vulnerable and sick residents at risk
for a spread
historically health care institutions
have established requirements for
vaccines as conditions of employment in
recent years there's been a move towards
increasing vaccine exemptions
unfortunately the coven 19 pandemic has
exacerbated conflicting beliefs
re-individual freedom and public health
and safety fueled by misinformation
about vaccines
individual reasons for decisions not to
vaccinate include the safety of a
vaccination and or its ingredients
religious or philosophical objections
fear of side effects and associated
illness and lack of urgency or priority
explained in part by the supposition
that hurt immunity will protect the
unvaccinated from infection
if an unvaccinated person encounters
another person that is infected with the
virus they too will become infected
regardless of human herd immunity
percentages
the legislation proposed in hb 1604
conflicts with health care providers
duty to protect self and others and may
interfere with the ability of
institutions to establish requirements
to maintain health and safety effective
protection of the public's health
mandates that all individuals receive
immunizations against vaccine
preventable diseases according to the
best and most current evidence outlined
by the cdc
the acip and all health care personnel
including registered nurses should be
vaccinated according to these
recommendations
finally as has already been noticed the
supreme court ruling upholding vaccine
requirements in facilities that accept
medicare and medicaid payments
could further jeopardize the health and
safety of all those involved including
and among other residents health care
providers pharmacists or housekeepers
the reduction or elimination of vaccine
preventable diseases is one of the
greatest public health achievements in
the united states
current evidence and research illustrate
that immunizations are essential to the
primary prevention of disease from
infancy through adulthood the new
hampshire nurses association urges the
committee to oppose h.b 1604
thank you in advance thank you so much
and will you take questions
i like doing the lunchtime questions
i want to thank you so much for
testifying before i
let the committee go i will close this
hearing but then i have a couple of
questions for the committee
this ends the hearing on house bill 1604
and the question i need to ask is
if
there is anyone
who wishes to work on an amendment
we will be executing this bill one way
or the other on tuesday and it would be
helpful to me in my preparation to know
are there people interested in this
you don't have to
you're
thinking of bringing forth an amendment
perhaps
if one is required i'm one is
it's totally up to you folks
representative weber
i'm not volunteering for this but i also
have a question of the chair when you're
finished with this particular issue okay
representative merchant
question to the chair i think also is to
um clarify i think going to be
clarification because the opening
statement really is not a statement it's
kind
of woven into the statute itself and i
think
if we go forward we have to have some
clarification on the intent of what it
means by humanization opening line
and no i'm not volunteering
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um so there was
question about that when the bill was
passed
up until
he asked the question and he's okay now
um there was there was question on that
when the bill was passed um
there was a faction of the public that
wanted it to apply to all vaccines and
there was a faction that wanted it
applied to just coven 19. and when um it
came down to the wire and the ag was
asked his opinion on it he said that
because
the second sentence starts with
accordingly
that the implication is that it only
applies to covid19 vaccines
okay not asking for an amendment i'm
just asking uh this is the time if one
person wants to work on it with others
everything goes out the door on this on
the eight so i don't see anything
representative webber you had a question
of the chair
it was
it was actually the chair and others uh
about 1439 might i inquire about
availability of the subcommittee for at
a particular time yes you may thank you
uh
the commit subcommittee as as detailed
by uh the chair and others
was myself representatives leon gay
kelsey
cushman woods nutteruppum and mckay
and
this is the bill relative to hospital
visitation policies with a particular
emphasis on end of life but also
throughout life and i was wondering if i
could schedule that at 8 30 on a tuesday
morning so that people would not have to
make a s
a special trip in
to consider that does anybody object to
that because i would do it not next
tuesday when we're under the gun with a
lot of execs and i think people might be
preparing for that but the next tuesday
and
i could then prepare calendar notices
for that if that's okay
hearing no objection i'm going to check
with representative kelsey since she's
out today but
okay thank you
uh we we've got a pretty good critical
mass at this point so
um i i as the clerk have a request if
someone could substitute for the clerk
during that meeting and take
the notes
the normal procedure on subcommittees is
one of the members and it may be the
chair but it may be another member does
take that and the
minute taking for subcommittees is very
minimal it's simply recording decisions
it's not recording as you do every
single comment by every single person
which is a great relief to anybody doing
that duty
but i will ensure that that's done and
the clerk may
be at leisure
so representative weber um perhaps after
hearing from representative kelsey who's
with us today uh then you would take
care of calendaring thank you so much
the other question i have to
raise is on the first bill we heard 12
prime sponsor representative baldazzaro
is presented by representative cushman
prohibiting
employers and public space people from
discriminating on back status and
several other things
again i'm not asking and i'm i'm not
making anything except if
there is a an individual or a group who
wishes to write an amendment to this
this bill too will go out the door on
the 8th with or without you so just just
inform me
does it look like there's anybody who's
going to do this
was this a question that we got the
answer to because i marked two places
whether we were
specifying
which immunization
that would be a question to anybody in
the room other than me please
yeah did that get solved already
in hb 1224
yes yes
yes that bill is specified
i believe yes
that one is
specific to covet 19 vaccination
so it looks like there isn't but should
someone on the drive home say
you want to write something wonderful
and get a group together just let me
know that's all so i can plan my work um
that
looks like
almost
it representative soloway
mr chairman i i have a piece of
information that just arrived may i
inform the committee is this
i'm sorry is it like late breaking news
this is late breaking news this is from
my uh informant at the cleveland clinic
uh this is dr jennifer tabon who says
the vaccine mandates are being removed
in the near future in florida and
colorado they're going to be removing
the vaccine mandates and mask mandates
essentially the pandemic is considered
over and that will be going into effect
toward the end of this month of february
if i may add to that a week ago friday i
informed my domestic partner
well it's over you can watch the numbers
drop beginning today the news media are
in fact reporting that hospitalizations
are way down for complex reasons the
deaths are going down
and we're probably seeing the end of
omicron currently omicron b is still out
there we don't know what that's going to
be like but it's very likely that we're
now
past the crisis
and that may affect our decisions on
legislation thank you mr chairman this
is why the chair kept these bills that
are early bills as late as i could to
see what happens and since you are an
epidemiologist
would you all buy lunch for us given
that great late-breaking news
one more announcement
thank you um
representative mckay
received copies of the mental health
10-year plan and a supplement from dhhs
so when you come back from lunch
that's what's going to be sitting at
your desk
i had hoped to end by 12 15 i apologize
for going over by one minute i will see
you at one o'clock
representative soloway i don't recall
your answer to that question
the question was because you're an
epidemiologist would you be buying lunch
first
yeah
i will accept that thank you
i am sure
hysterical though
commissioner peer support specialists
work together and sometimes they go to
the police the police will request we go
with them or vice versa
and uh yes but anyway it's
it works very well and you know
basically the intent there
is
because right now it would be nice if
you could instantly go right into
treatment
department of justice health human
services
i asked my son
what are you most scared
there's no financial fraud
just keep in trouble who we are for some
foreign
[Music]
is it's a church one
what if they
i love going on pinterest it's a
you know
and so
but
one day i had clicked on something on
there and the very next day on my
facebook page one of the ads was for
that same thing
like my goodness gracious
yes
two more bills and then if we have some
time exec a couple more just to
have a time next week
um
next
tuesday there are no scheduled bills
because we have to finish all the execs
by then
and then we've got
a list of bills
that we haven't even heard yet the rest
of them yes
i cannot believe how many bills
it's just crazy
yes
well i didn't think so
we reopened the exact session on
is
then we do the new otp
it's only four roll calls
i think i think i should get some award
i think i should get some award
yeah proof it yeah
but she said no you probably shouldn't
do that we should you shouldn't
flown in at great expense from right
over there
open the hearing on house bill
prohibiting health care providers from
refusing to provide care or services
based on patient vaccination status
presenting herbal the prime sponsor
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee
um my name is representative leah
cushman i'm
representing hillsborough county
district two wear and deering and i'm
bringing you this bill house bill 1003.
um
this bill inserts language into the
residential care and health facility
licensing chapter
so it only applies to patients admitted
to a facility those facilities that we
discussed
on
a previous bill
would be nursing homes hospitals
dialysis centers
day surgery centers
so anything that falls under that
statute 151
um so
the premise of the bill
is
we live in a
culture of increasing
hostility towards people who
make a medical decision to not
participate in vaccination
and
i have mentioned previously that
from my background as a nurse
i took my code of ethics seriously and
when i was told it's part of my
responsibility to advocate for patient
self-determination that
i
i took that
wholeheartedly
um the american medical association
recommends not refusing
care to patients who
decline vaccination in a way that
discriminates based on a class of people
they do encourage making adjustments in
the manner of serving them if they feel
it's necessary such as having rooms
set aside for unvaccinated or having
them come in for visits at a certain
time of day if they feel that that's
necessary
so the conversation in the literature
medical ethics literature has changed
over the years
since i graduated nursing school
in 2014.
during that time medical ethicists were
saying it's absolutely a doctor's duty
to continue seeing unvaccinated patients
even in primary care settings not only
in emergency care
and now there's a shift in the culture
[Music]
of medicine to not only deny care to
unvaccinated but
there is some interest in the
effectiveness of using shaming
and
using fear as a means of
um encouraging vaccination
so there's been a real change in how
these people are approached um when it
comes to health care
so
for me it's just another representation
of how far medicine has fallen
as a practice where doctors can refuse
patient care based on a medical decision
people decline vaccinations for all
kinds of reasons religious moral ethical
or based on their assessment of benefit
versus risk
we believe in informed consent right
as health care providers doctors and
nurses are expected to ensure patients
have informed consent
but
how does that add up when we decide that
their decision is unacceptable and say
well if that's your decision we can't
treat you
that's not impo in really providing
informed consent or acknowledging
patient self-determination
so
if an immuno-compromised patient refuses
to take an immunostimulator to reduce
their risk of infection
would a doctor refuse them
because they are at increased risk of
infection and therefore it increased
risk of
passing on that infection
so
if a doctor wouldn't do that why would
we refuse someone who doesn't take a
vaccine it's the same premise
how how about morbidly obese patients
who refuse to change their diet or
diabetics who don't take their insulin
and end up with infected leg wounds that
nurses have to care for daily
putting them at risk of mrsa and other
antibiotic resistant bacterial
infections you know we have to get right
up personal
in our you know sometimes get our faces
in these things
and despite the damage to our backs and
the risk of infection that we face
we don our ppe and we take care of those
patients we don't turn them away and we
take care of them with love and
compassion
the bill just says you can't deny care
based on vaccination status
it doesn't doesn't mean that if a
patient is combative or
um
you know
for other reasons
that you would deny care that you can't
um if we had a robust alternative health
care system in new hampshire
i might
i might say that this bill isn't
necessary but where we have a heavily
corporate monolithic health care system
especially where hospitals are concerned
and that's the area that this bill
addresses i think that it is needed
so i'm i'm concerned about most nursing
homes don't have any vaccine
requirements and don't discriminate on
vaccination status i'm really concerned
about hospitals there have been some
cases around the country a
three-year-old was
denied heart treatment because parents
the parents were unvaccinated
that's just a headline and that was
actually in europe
but an unvaccinated patient of a boston
hospital was denied a heart transplant
because he wasn't vaccinated
and if you just
search the internet you'll find similar
cases and i have received
reports from
the general public
of parents being
let go from specialists that their
children needed
from being dismissed from
private practices
based on vaccination status and this
bill doesn't apply to private practices
i think there is some more
room for lateral movement for patients
to shop around and find a different
doctor
but i'm open to
having that discussion if we if that's
something the committee wants to include
that's about it
thank you representative weber
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much representative cushing for taking
my question
so you were talking about hospitals and
access to hospitals
but as far as i know the department of
health and human services is involved in
only one hospital
being the new hampshire
hospital
the other hospitals are all entities
unto themselves and while they may have
to comply with certain department
regulations
it's not the department of health and
human services that's requiring anything
it would be the entity themselves
so how does this apply in those cases
so
um this bill isn't just specific to the
department of health and human services
it's to all
medical facilities that are regulated by
that um
statute
it's
151 sorry do i have do i have the wrong
bill
what bill are we on one zero zero three
ah i have the wrong bill okay my
deepest apologies this is what i
get for being late to class and my
apologies thank you for the
clarification but hold that thought
because you're on a good roll i will
hold that phone okay representative
woods yeah thank you mr chair and thanks
for taking my question uh just a query
about the
uh rather broad-based
inclusion i'm trying to think of
potential exceptions uh say an oncology
service that has people who are
really immunosuppressed and then
not to being able to say
well no in this facility we need to have
everybody vaccinated to care for these
particularly immune compressed or
compromised patients similarly
like two of my very close friends here
in concord have heart transplants
and
they can't even with vaccines they can't
get uh their titers up they have to be
protected and if they had open clinics
uh without some regulation uh
uh that would be rather significant
uh is there any
exceptions
for this in the way you it doesn't look
like there's any exception for anybody
for anything
so
it just states that they can't
discriminate they can't deny care or
services based on vaccination status so
they could still
if they wanted to separate appointment
times and have all the unvaccinated
patients come at the end of the day or
you know only be seen on a certain day
they they could still make policies like
that if they wanted to
um
but again
currently there's still no guarantee
even that the employees in that facility
won't be vaccinated given the the
exemptions available
representative canark thank you very
much sort of as a follow-on i um
i appreciate and agree that you we
shouldn't be discriminating whether
we're going to care for somebody uh you
know we
we still take care of people who have
you know our smokers and get lung cancer
we take care of them
the question is sometimes there's
medical issues for example you brought
up heart transplants and there's a
number of
uh factors that go into deciding who
gets a heart because we don't have
enough of them
and or liver transplants if i remember
right we don't usually do liver
transplants and people will continue to
drink
uh because we know it's just gonna fail
um so would there would it be reasonable
to say something in the order of
uh based on a patient's vaccination
status comma unless there are medical
indic medical reasons to do so or that's
kind of vague too i can't figure out a
good wording but there are some times
when this might possibly come in i think
it'd be rare
in terms of a decision making for
something that would be
medical though not because you didn't
like it because they didn't get
vaccinated but because of the increased
medical risk or something along that
hill could i i'm not sure how to word it
what's your thoughts on that one
um i'm open to discussing it uh
like you i i don't see it
i see it being a really rare occurrence
where that would be the only factor that
would
preclude a medical
treatment or
procedure from going forward
um
but we yeah i'd be open to discuss it
certainly
follow up um i'll i'll try to think back
but would you believe that back when we
first had hiv that was an issue because
we faced it with things that were
elective like hardware removals from
ankle fractures and the concern of
increased risk and we spent a lot of
time
in the hospital trying to figure out how
do we handle that situation i'll try to
think back to figure out how we worded
some of these things and get back to you
on it i'll work with you
and now the chair calls on the honorable
gentlelady from cheshire county with a
question on house bill 1003
well and i know it was on 1003 because
representative kenner really made me ask
the question that i was going to ask
about
those procedures where we deny for all
kinds of different factors and they may
be obesity they may be refusable to stop
drinking they may be
you know
scarce
medical resources
and you have to
decide as ethically as possible
how you are going to
not only do no harm but do the most
benefit
and so i i think we were driving at the
same thing so i thank you for your
willingness to consider that
representatives excuse me
you may answer if you wish
representative cushman
oh thank you um
yeah so my thought is that
not being vaccinated in and of itself
you know a year ago when there was no
vaccine
not being vaccinated wouldn't preclude
somebody from
obtaining a procedure um like a heart
transplant or anything so i don't i
personally don't
think it's an acceptable reason to not
um
even elective procedures to not go
forward with them
the speaker of the house had me do a
deep dive research on the issue of
transplants
and would you believe that what i
learned among other things
was that there were many factors that
would push an individual up or down on
the transplant list
one of which would be
um the likelihood of survival of this
individual in receiving the transplant
versus that individual
and that would you then believe that
it's not the only answer but it's a
valid answer in the question
that lack of vaccination status could be
seen by some reasonable people
as something that would push them down
the list
on a case-by-case basis
yes okay you can see that
representative soloway uh thank you mr
chairman
and representative cushman thank you for
taking my question it's a two-part
question i do want to point out however
that we have visitors in the gallery
and we are being on our best behavior
we've not done it this year but we can
try
um
are not
practitioners and organizations already
bound by their ethical systems
uh i would assume that they are but the
ethics around how we treat unvaccinated
people has changed a lot in the last
year or two
so
i've seen
an increased tendency toward
a new
a new understanding of what
the ethical way to treat them would be
okay a quick follow-up follow-up um i i
was moved by
of your presentation
of the numbers of diagnoses
that might require this kind of
protection
i thought that you did a really good job
on that but the way the bill is written
would this not open up the door to add a
longer and longer list of diagnoses
that require protection we've seen this
with other bills that we've dealt with
in this session
in particular on the bill on migraines
uh would we
open up the door there to a long series
of diagnoses would we not be opening up
the same door here
thank you for your question um
i didn't add a list of diagnoses there's
no language for that in the bill it's
just
um
that there's a prohibition on refusal to
care
refusal to provide care services based
on vaccination status
you could generalize it
rather than just vaccines
you could come up with language on
any pre-existing condition
does that make sense
yeah sure i mean i'd be open to discuss
um
you know a different way to word it sure
yeah thank you so much representative uh
before we continue the chair wishes to
reconsider a previous remark that
perhaps was not worded well that yes we
are on our best behavior and this is
something this committee has noted for
and uh thank you for the look i got from
a one-time second grade teacher that
encouraged me to do this
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
that clarification and welcome thank you
for joining us today
thank you representative for taking
these questions and i appreciate the
other questions around denial of care
would you be comfortable if this list of
diagnoses that are excluded
is written so that a patient with
with with a disease that has a lot of
immune compromise
say somebody with that needs treatment
in one of these oncology clinics
or needs to be seen by the transplant
center perhaps they already have a
transplant
would you be comfortable with excluding
those patients from care even though the
other patients with the same diagnosis
have their have a more elevated risk
sorry i probably didn't worry that
clearly i'm saying can you ask again
okay so
okay i'm i'm gonna back up and rewind
the tape uh we're looking at some of
these patient groups that are very
vulnerable
and without treatment whether those who
any of those patients without treatment
may end up either much sicker or die
we're talking about the idea of
protecting those patients who are
vaccinated and potentially excluding the
unvaccinated are we are you comfortable
denying life-saving care to somebody
simply because others with the same
diagnosis
might be at higher risk from covet
exposure
oh no i am not comfortable with that
thank you
thank you for the question
representative snow
well we're halfway home we've got the
microphone in front of you the next step
why is it i'm the only one that has
trouble with these things
i can't we hide it better uh i know i
know
at the beginning of your testimony you
indicated this bill is really like the
other bill we looked at that was
really aimed at health care facilities
nursing homes etc
and yet the wording of the bill says
providers which seems to indicate
individual private practice etc would
this bill be easier for people to
understand
if that one word
where it says providers was just simply
changed to facilities
i think
in the case of an individual press so
under that statute i believe provider
includes facilities
under the arts by the way i'll say 151.
but it also includes individual private
practitioners who are
one-on-one
you know particularly in behavioral
health
i think some
are perfectly aware that they have an
attitude about vaccination where they
really wouldn't be as much help
to the
patient as someone else would who's not
kept the same attitude about it so that
you might
want to do that but i mean i i thought
you were aiming at facilities that
facilities couldn't turn people away
because of vaccination status not any
individual practitioner
i personally
can't imagine doing it i i'm very strong
on
masks and the other but i would not
refuse to see somebody who was not
vaccinated representative connerk
yes but um
this camera i'm going to make i'm not
going to make it a question 151 does
have to do with facilities it's not
providers so since it is in 151 she's
got the right place i think
so you you support the idea of keeping
that word providers
uh no crosstalk until the uh that's okay
until the executive session i don't know
why but that's the rule representative
merchant
thank you mr chairman
and also thank you representative
um just for clarification would you
believe that in
colon 21
section 4
it says health care provider means any
person corporation facility
institutionally licensed by the state
and goes on providing health care
services including not limited to a
physician hospital health care facility
dentist nurse optometrist podiatrist
physical therapist
psychologist any office
officer employer employee or agent
providing such care in the facility so
health care provider
does
would you believe that
yeah i would believe that and
the purpose of the bill is to make it so
that no one has refused care for
vaccination status so if that's an
individual provider
or a facility
i would like to see
protection for these patients and make
sure they can still receive care
follow-up
matt
inquirer i guess is what is the impetus
of the spill because you have in my
opinion
so to hit the nail on the head ethically
as a clinician
we're not
able to in a sense refuse treatment to a
patient
so i'm not quite sure exactly what is
triggering the bill to begin with what
the problem is that we're trying to
solve
because from an ethical point of view
providers are bound to take care of the
patient regardless of their status
and i'm not sure exactly why this is
coming forth to this committee
thank you for the question uh well
i've received reports from many parents
here's one dr
al
i'll take out the name is a wonderful
dermatologist
who specializes in dermatology
um called to make an appointment the
voice message
said you would not be seen if
unvaccinated
um here's another one we got kicked out
of
my son's pcp for not being vaccinated
names the
primary care doctor
here's another one
we got kicked out of
our doctor years ago
for not being vaccinated we got kicked
out
i have like several
um and those were just for the last two
days when i asked and those are
those were mostly pcps and specialists
um
and like i said that there is
a
more free market
for that
practice and i think there's more
options to find a different primary care
doctor
so
that's why i think that the facilities
where people would be admitted which is
what this speaks to
are the ones that i would like to ensure
won't refuse patience on that
um i have the chair has a question um i
know
that the facility of which i'm ceo
uh can and occasionally does
dismiss patients from the practice
and
of course we give them 30 days to find
someone else if they can and all the
forwarding of medical records and
whatnot
would this be a carve-out saying that we
can do that but not for this specific
reason
because we can dismiss them
as a facility
and my facility does it on the say so of
one of my several pcps
is this saying we can do that but not
for this
thank you for the question mr chairman
um so it wouldn't apply to
your business
but yes the
the um facilities licensed under that
statute 151
they would still be able to dismiss a
patient for other reasons could they
dismiss for this reason no
okay so this is a carve out of which
there could be some others say you don't
like people with aids or whatever
i mean this this could lead to a second
one could it not
a second a second carve out
you must you can dismiss people for any
reason you want except for
vaccine status and then next year for
another status and so on well the so
this is in the patient bill of rights
and there are already you know reasons
that patients can't be denied care under
that um they can't be denied or
dismissed if they
um have medicaid they can't if
they um can't pay
they can't be denied based on their race
or gender or
um
age are you saying that a patient cannot
be dismissed for the patient's steadfast
refusal to pay the copay
that's for these facilities that's what
it says
yeah and rsa
right and that's what this applies to
i've got a note handed up here that john
williams
who does not just work for the dhhs but
is also a font of wisdom
is willing to speak to this issue
and the only drawback is we don't have
one
but he's being brought into the room
while he's doing that um
i just know from having numbers of
family members who are
career medical providers the oaths that
they take
and they really do lean heavily towards
treating people irrespective of so thank
you john williams and
your
the term is extern
well it takes turns obviously
definitely the committee with the best
sense of humor so uh thank you very much
for allowing uh myself john williams for
the record the director of legislative
affairs and with me
janice emery legal intern with
dhhs and i just want to thank the
committee and also the prime sponsor of
the bill uh you know for allowing us to
come up before you just on a very
limited capacity we're here to provide
information uh a conversation uh came up
and i have to say that representative
weber always attends the right class in
the right school because i actually
think you were probably perhaps on the
right issue relative to the placement of
this law within our facilities licensing
statute under 151. if you read the
language and i'm actually going to have
janice read us the language starting on
line three down ending on line five
no health care provider licensed or
registered to provide services in this
state may refuse to provide care or
services based on a patient's
vaccination status
and miss emery do we license providers
under this section or facilities
we
do not license
providers
thank you so the correct placement for
this if the consideration is to having
it apply to
uh the provider's licensure as opposed
to the facility licensure and it's
clearly written so that it applies to
providers
and so therefore the the appropriate
placement at least as it relates to
physicians and surgeons would be under
rsa chapter 329 and just putting it out
there for your consideration and open to
the questions from the committee
dr representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
excuse me
under general practice
we've heard that the physicians and
facilities are refusing because of this
issue and therefore you're right
physicians at least from the standpoint
are controlled by the board of medicine
and have a certain standard at which
they can practice
have any of these been brought to the
board of medicine
that we heard i had my hand up to ask
the
prime sponsor but
i was not able to get in
do you know
or would you have an opinion as to
whether this
would be the venue of the board of
medicine
if a physician were in fact refute or a
facility was refusing
you know physician visa borough medicine
um it seemed like that would be the
avenue to to start
to begin with
yes
okay so realistically the question that
was posed at the department as i filter
out all of the first one do we have any
information uh from the office of
professional licensure and board of
medicine on the frequency of these kind
of complaints i do not because that's
not our agency it's another agency
perhaps there's other members in the
audience that i think are very prepared
to provide you with that level of
background information on that question
number one number two is because we're
talking about
uh if you're looking at and and we're
just working off the language in the
build in front of us that talks about
providers that if we're talking about
providers and not facilities the
appropriate location for that would be
in the professional licensure statute
and if it is related to physicians and
surgeons and looking in anticipation for
a question from representative merchant
that they are regulated by the board of
medicine at least as to those entities
there's perhaps other providers that the
bill sponsor may want to include in that
list this was not meant to be all
exhausted list but we just wanted to
identify that the appropriate location
should not be in rsa 151 which only
licensed facilities and even if you were
to consider doing that we would actually
suggest other placement as well if
you're going to go down that route so we
hope you don't and uh and again we're
not taking a position on the bill
but in the spirit of trying to get you
the appropriate place where it belongs
we're trying to be helpful
that you've now received this bill in
front of you as as drafted
representative cushman would you be able
to address representative woods question
as to whether such offending
providers have been duly reported to the
board of medicine
thank you representative woods for the
question i
do not have
information on whether those were
but i do know that non-disciplinary
action when they investigate complaints
if there's no official disciplinary
action taken it's not
made public
so it could be that it has but it's not
on the website
of actions taken follow-up
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair uh but i guess my
real question is do you know if any of
these individuals have in fact
approached the board of medicine to at
least initiate
that comment it would still that
individual if that were the case if they
were no a non-disciplinary action taken
that would still be a notification to
the patient the patient then would know
and would have to get a reason okay for
that non-disciplinary reason it you're
true it would not be publicized
uh as disciplinary or that that's in the
public domain and in fact they're it's i
mean every one is published their anyway
but uh so
you're not sure
no i don't have confirmation that any of
them filed complaints with the uh board
of medicine
thank you representative merchant
thank you mr chairman i also think that
kristen cushman has taken the question
so i'm trying to understand and break it
apart there's the facility side
and the provider
so in essence what dhhs does is
regulates the facility
and therefore they could talk about the
access to the provider who's in the
facility
which is different than a provider who's
in the facility so this could
allow the facility to grant access it
doesn't mean the provider who's in that
facility
has he has an obligation to ethically
treat the patient but if they don't back
the representative wood's comment
wouldn't that go back to the board of
medicine as a
violation of ethics
uh i wonder if it would um
i would i would think so but
i uh
so where i put this in is the bill of
rights right patient bill of rights for
patients who are admitted to medical
facilities and um now that we've been
talking about the phrasing i noticed
that it the phrasing of this bill the
language deviates from the pattern
that's in that bill of rights
all of the other rights of patients
start with the patient shall so i wonder
if it would be appropriate to amend the
bill and make it say the patient shall
not be denied care based on
vaccination status
follow-up
i totally agree with what you're saying
i think it's probably better in that
location and i think we should also talk
about the provider separately maybe in
rsa 329 although i'm dangerous about
doing that because once we do that in
rsa329 that deals only with physicians
position assistants it doesn't deal with
dentists podiatrists optometrists and so
forth so if we go down that road we
should be sure we amend all the other
rsas dealing with those providers but if
you're willing to work with you on it
i would believe that
sorry weber
well once again i think we may have gone
a long way towards addressing my concern
which was
this is very very broad language in a
very very specific statute so if you
mean it to apply
as the patient bill of rights does
because it's in this chapter to patients
who are in residential care and health
facilities
then it ought to say
either either use the language proposed
by representative merchant or say
in several prominent places under this
chapter
so that we know that it is limited
to
the facilities but i don't think that's
your intent and the language here is
very very broad
and as as representative merchant has
already pointed out
uh would you believe that if that is
your intent that you need to get into
all the other statutes which is
a matter of some delicacy
having remembered all the negotiations
that had to do with
everybody who could prescribe opiates
which unfortunately
included patients that were not only
two-legged but four-legged and had very
different considerations so luckily
you're out of that one but but there are
a lot of different places in the statute
that it has to go
and my other question is
did you intend
to
include all vaccination or simply covet
vaccination because it does not the
language here does not restrict to the
covert vaccination
it would include every single one of the
vaccinations that we have been using
for many many years and as the child of
a polio survivor
i am very grateful
for the climate in which i was born
where everybody went and got the polio
vaccine
so
uh thank you is it your intent that it
apply to everything or just covet thank
you for your question it is my intent
that it apply to all vaccinations
thank you
representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson and thank you
for taking my question
um i want to put a scenario and make
sure i've got this right so a person who
presents say at an emergency room and is
admitted to the emergency room
has presented with some very specific um
possible issues that require certain
protocols
and as soon as it's found out that that
person did not
get vaccinated that all those protocols
were then
pushed aside
would i not i wouldn't have
in this i would
it wasn't the facility's fault
it was what happened after i was already
admitted well i must say hi but um
i think i'm sorry would i then
are we talking then we um someone would
have to go to the board of
medicine
for
to report an issue
rather than
reporting to dhs
thank you for the question
i'm not sure how that would play out
um i would think that the
doctor wouldn't want to violate
you know the provider wouldn't want to
violate
the
patient bill of rights that governs the
facility that they work at
um
and i think both would be
you know responsible in that situation
but i'm not i'm not sure the board of
medicine could probably weigh in um but
to speak to your scenario i actually
knew um
know somebody who was hospitalized in
massachusetts and
was had a ruptured appendix
and
was admitted and
when they found out that
this person was unvaccinated
and also was refusing testing
they changed they completely changed
their course of treatment they were
going to do surgery and
instead they drained an abscess and put
them on iv antibiotics and said that
they were going to discharge them that
night so it does happen
i think they could have just treated him
as a presumed coveted positive and
didn't need to go all of that
to change the course of treatment but
that brings up one of the issues and why
the bill is needed
i have a question um from the chair i
don't see any penalties in here is it
assumed
that if somebody's reported to the board
of medicine or facility to dhhs
licensing those two organizations would
take care of any penalties to be meted
out
i believe those are the two
bodies that would be dealing with this
yes
okay representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
as we're looking at this and looking at
enforcement possibly through the board
of medicine are you aware that they
will issue confidential warnings prior
to action that are not disclosed to
anyone and do you think it would be a
good idea if perhaps we're sending such
big ethical issues to the board that
perhaps redacted
statements of these should be going to
healthcare hhs oversight committee just
so that they can review a basic redacted
one to make sure that these things
aren't happening because if it's
confidential they're not able to discuss
it
thank you representative and um i'm
sorry if i haven't said thank you to you
guys when you're asking all your
questions
um
yeah i i think that that would be a good
idea to add an additional layer of
oversight um
and kind of in that same vein where we
were just talking about uh penalty
this statute in general has had some
violations as we saw when we had the
bill hb
1439 about
ensuring that patients have visitors
some of that has been violated and
there are no teeth in this law so may be
something else we consider
representative snow
thank you mr chairman yes just a very
quick question
um every healthcare facility that i go
with every practitioner that i go to
today require me to wear a mask when i'm
being seen
and i think if i were going and
to go and
if if the practitioner said i'm not
going to see you
because you're not vaccinated but if
instead they said
i'm not going to see you if you won't
wear a mask do you see e that is would
that be a legitimate reason to refuse to
see him versus saying i'm not going to
see you if you have colgan
thank you for the question
i think a mask can be taken off
and you know can be worn temporarily a
vaccination can't you can't undo it so i
think it's
you know
so you would have no problem
you're not saying that refusal
uh refusal to wear the mask while you're
face to face with a practitioner
would not
be you would not have a problem with
that according to this bill correct this
bill doesn't touch on masking at all
thank you
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for
um taking this question i'm i'm still
after all this conversation i'm still
baffled if we're talking about
facilities or providers are we talking
about
outpatient
appointments within facilities or just
in residential
services but regardless
if this bill were to pass would you um
would you see
telehealth appointments
when
when um medically
um applicable
as a an alternative to face-to-face
appointments with someone who
is unvaccinated in other words if uh if
a health care provider said i'm not
going to see you in person but i will
see you in a telehealth appointment
would that um
would that be
go along with the
spirit of this bill
thank you for the question
representative i i think it would
like i said
um
they can they can dictate different
policies to try to mitigate risk
you know it doesn't doesn't say they
can't do that you just can't
the purpose of the bill the intent of
the bill is just so that you can't just
deny care outright
based on vaccination status alone
it's not really a follow-up but it's
another question another question it
seems like in my experience
[Music]
the
issue of denying care
before someone starts in your care
as opposed to after you've been treating
somebody or somewhat different
[Music]
practitioners
i believe have a lot more leeway in
saying that they're not going to treat
someone
who they haven't treated before as
opposed to their ethical
um responsibilities once they're already
in treatment with them
so
would your bill apply to both situations
um if someone is first knocking on your
door or
you've been treating them
you know before
[Music]
you knew about their vaccination status
would it apply to both
i believe it would apply to both in
these in this setting
so this setting is
um for admitted residents or patients of
healthcare facilities
thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative
um
i'm not quite sure how to
ask this
but the subject of
whether this is really an issue right
now
uh
yesterday
driving here listening to the news i
found out that a woman that i know
i didn't know her name but she waited on
me at the post office for 30 years in
salem
that she died
after the hospital
in in a around boston
refused her
monoclonal antibodies
so then they asked for old medication
they refused ivermectin
they refused the best kind of respirator
and then they refused to transfer her to
a different hospital
she died
so
i'm
asking have you heard anything
worse than that
i have not heard anything worse than
that and my
second question is
if
oh
since this seems to be
from the help of everybody who's
commenting
it seems like in line four
would to because it's mentioning 151 21
on line three
to make it match 151 21
then would would it be better to say
instead of no health care provider
licensed or registered
may refuse to make it match we'd say no
health care facility
and then for the providers
amend it so that it adds the other
appropriate rsas that cover those others
thank you for your question um to your
second point
um amending it and adding the rsas that
govern specific providers
would cover the providers
but i think the issue with the language
here and the statute that it
the patient bill of rights is that
the rest of that statute the
the rights are listed as the patient
shall so it would an amendment to change
it to the patient shall not be denied
care based on vaccination status would
be an appropriate amendment one more
question
one more
okay
we were seemingly
wondering about the teeth
if somebody's violating this and what
what could dhhs do
wouldn't the absolute
sharpest teeth be
if you're breaking the rules
we just withhold your
license i don't know that that would be
the sharpest but it would be pretty
sharp
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
would you
view transferring care to another
practitioner either in that facility or
another one is denying care or would
that be another way for a particularly
vulnerable or concerned practitioner to
to maintain care for that patient but
not personally be involved
thank you for the question no i wouldn't
i wouldn't view that as denying care i
think that would be a good option for
patients within a facility i mean
providers within a facility thank you
representative weber
well i had a question but i have a
follow-up to representative leon's
question first and wouldn't rewording
the statute to say the patient shall
solve some of that problem because the
patient has a right to care then but the
patient does not necessarily have a
right to be cared for by me
if i have a problem but there is
somebody else who is qualified to
deliver the care that the patient needs
who is going to
provide the care it it allows a great
deal more room for
providers
to also exercise their individual rights
is that true
yes i would agree thank you for the
question
and follow up follow up um and i had one
other word
question is would you be willing to
consider
uh
i'm having a hard time remembering how
to phrase it because we're changing the
phrasing but
um
uh it would be
no patience shall be denied and would
you object to adding the word solely on
the basis of vaccination status because
i'm concerned about the cases
where there are three
other
reasons that we
deem valid i mean and then
having a patient say oh no i have to be
treated because of the other
the other one
yes sir thank you for the question
i i would not object to inserting the
word solely and i actually thought about
that too so thank you so that that would
help thank you
representative woods
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
again for taking my question uh would
you believe uh
relative to a
phrase we heard earlier about confident
about confidential uh warnings uh that
often confidential warnings are meant to
be confidential to allow the person in
that case a provider physician involved
to respond and clarify and sometimes i
was involved in one such episode when i
was a practicing physician that there
was a miscommunication
and the reason
uh that it was confidential it allowed
me a chance to respond and clarify
uh so i just just i wanted that
are you aware that that confidential
mechanism is in place
i was not aware but i would believe it
uh
follow up
yes uh thank you um
also uh i think it's uh relative to uh
representative folsom
are you aware that oftentimes a
physician who may be in private practice
and then a facility purchases their
practice
and that then will change
some of the parameters in which they can
both economically as as well as actual
day-to-day uh procedures
so uh that can come into play and
therefore the it
makes it cloudy between if it's just for
the provider
the facility may be impacting his
response but are you aware that that
creates a little bit of a
difficulty i understand uh i think i
understand your question um so but this
particular chapter is
describes the rights and
responsibilities of each patient
admitted to a facility
except those admitted by a home health
care provider so these are for patients
who are
admitted to
the hospital or a nursing home um not
those
who are
you know seeing a specialist in a clinic
inside of one of those hospitals
i'm just
going to fall just to
make sure that we clarify because we're
talking provider being physician versus
facility and i think that has to be a
distinction
because of some of the economic
uh
relationships that some of these
providers versus facilities have and
will impact what you're trying to do
thank you yeah um yeah i understand what
you're saying so
uh
i mean language to clarify i'm not
against but it seems like
there's some movement on
including providers also instead of just
facilities so i guess
[Music]
any other questions
for the representative
seeing none thank you so much
the chair calls uh catherine michelotti
who has filled out a pink card she comes
from derry
and wishes to speak in support of the
bill thank you so much for coming hi
thank you rep chairman for accepting my
ques or my testimony i guess and thank
you everyone for having us here
um i would like to testify as a parent
who has been
has had my child denied care for
vaccination status
prior to covid even
because a child one of my children had a
reaction to a vaccine
as a young infant
and my doctor in another state had said
please make sure this child does not get
this vaccine again and despite that
record being transferred
to the state where we lived at the time
the provider would
refuse to care for my child and so we
had to go on a physician search when my
son was dealing with lyme disease and
his lyme disease was unchecked for
months
while i tried to find a physician who
would see him because he had not had a
pneumococcal vaccine
and so i would like to
put my support behind this bill because
i think it's very important for more
than just
current vaccines that are new
thank you thank you would you take any
questions from the i'd be happy
committee yes
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking my question
when that happened
was there a complaint filed with the
board of medicine or the board
overseeing that practitioner about the
issue of violating what i consider to be
their ethics which the boards take
seriously
to be honest there wasn't
as a mom who was dealing with a very
sick kiddo i didn't even know that was
an option
i was just really concerned with finding
someone who would take care of my child
and i did not know that that was
something i could do and i have a
feeling i'm not the only one
who knows you know if i'm denied care oh
there's some there's steps i can take i
did not know and i kind of wish i had
weber
thank you and my question i got a little
confused in the in the moves between
physicians uh was the care denied in new
hampshire or was the care denied
somewhere else
thank you for the question um the care
was denied in massachusetts thank you
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
now let's see if i can get welch gaelic
correct
euan
aegwynn
we know the answer i cannot get welch
gaelic correct without help awin osborne
sorry for mispronouncing your name
do you know what it means
what do you know what your name means um
i'm not quite sure there's a lot of
different
takes on it
but it's a pretty name
thank you for coming and uh thank you
for allowing me to testify today and for
uh
listening to me even though i probably
am going to make zero sense
okay
since the beginning of when covid
vaccines were first released to the
general public the unvaccinated have
faced so much discrimination because of
their decision
not to inject potentially harmful
substances into their bodies
and
i personally personally believe that
denying someone healthcare because
of what they choose to do um
with their with their selves is
completely
terrible i i don't think it should be
legal
um furthermore i think it violates the
hippocratic oath which
all medical
service providers i think take and it
says that they will not do
any harm and denying someone care is
doing harm to someone
um
and um
speaking as someone who can't get the
vaccine um
i have an anxiety diagnosis and to me
and to my mother and to
whatever doctor would have to administer
the vaccine to me
it's not worth the panic attack it's not
worth
whatever it's going to cause i've also
had a bad reaction to a vaccine before
and for me i really just can't risk it
and the fact that i could be denied
life-saving
health care because of it
just doesn't sit right with me
and
i think i can say the same for my
friends and family as well
i guess that's it
would you take questions from everyone
in the room who wishes you would be our
honorary daughter or granddaughter
yeah yes i i i'd be happy to take
questions thank you
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming
your granddaughter about your age and i
understand your
difficulties
i just uh
would you believe
and i hope you believe
that under no circumstances
would you be done any care that was even
remotely
life-threatening
we would never
deny you care in that regard
um
i don't really understand what you're
asking
this is a way we make speeches with it
looking like we're asking questions
we just want you to know from the
medical community that we do care
and that that may not seem like it at
times
and sometimes we as physicians
believe it or not physicians have been
known make the wrong decisions in some
circumstances and that weighs as heavily
on us
as us
as it does you
trust me i've been there many times as a
as a surgeon
and it's it's
we weigh on this very
very
and we carry it with us
day to day
and
night to night
when things don't go quite right
so we appreciate but just we want you to
know when i speak i'm sure for the whole
medical community we do care
and we will take care of you
thank you so much i really appreciate
that
representative weber
a one-time second grade teacher
a one-time second grade teacher but i i
also have a would you believe question
which is how we ask questions without
how we make statements without asking
questions
but
would you believe that your testimony
here today
was really impressive
even without your age and even without
anxiety issues
so the fact that you were able to do it
what you did
is
really
really great
and would you believe that at your age i
could no more have done what you just
did than i could have grown wings and
flown
so you are well on your way
to becoming an advocate for whatever you
want to advocate for in your life as you
go forward you're already way ahead of
the game and thank you for coming
thank you so much i really appreciate
that it means a lot
representative gay
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you very
much for testifying and my question is
for the
for the excellent presentation you've
made
how old are you
i'm 14 almost 15. thank you for the
question well thank you so much and when
you turn 18
sign up and run for the house would you
would put you right in this committee
we'll all be still there
thank you thank you
and amelia jacques
jacks jacques
no
okay
decline
rusen chester from bedford
absolutely it's r-u-s-s-a-n
first three letters of russell first
three letters of sandra
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um i'm not going to
tell you lots of stories because you've
had folks have already heard a lot of
them from me
the only thing that i will say is that
i am vaccine injured i have a
granddaughter that that's vaccine
injured
from another state we had to have her
come to new hampshire to get treatment
because she was denied treatment
in the other state and she is now being
denied treatment in this state
so
i also wanted to let you folks know that
i have filed complaints with the boards
the medical board
one of the things is you don't know
they don't ever tell you what the
consequence or the the outcome of those
complaints are even as someone who files
a complaint um what i can tell you is 12
years after i filed my first complaint
about a specific doctor he was
he did lose his license to practice but
that was 12 years after my first
complaint and i really don't know how
many people it took to complain against
him before he was
his license was pulled
so that's it i just wanted to put myself
out there so if any of you folks have
any questions um to want us to want to
question me with regards to
any of my personal experiences i'm more
than welcome
thank you so much representative connerk
just a quick question was the person the
story you told was that person did not
care because of their vaccination status
or because of the treatment they they
were requesting they were denied care
because of their vaccination status it
was not covet 19 vaccine
and solely vaccination status
thank you so much for being with us
again
michael padmore from the new hampshire
medical society
good afternoon
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee my name is mike padmore
i'm the director of advocacy with the
new hampshire medical society
i'm here today to speak in opposition to
hb1003
not based on the intent of the bill and
listening to the bill sponsor i think
that we all agree on a number of
different things but i think that
our opposition more comes from uh we
feel that uh the intent of the the bill
is covered by uh the current statute um
a physician's responsibility to treat
patients without prejudice or
discrimination is a key component of the
american medical association's
code of ethics which all physicians are
required to adhere by in statute through
administrative rule med10 excuse me
501.02
which the new hampshire board of
medicine is charged with enforcing
any patient who believes
that a physician has violated this
and those ethical rules does have
recourse to file a complaint with board
of medicine which we obviously have seen
some folks talk about that today
we agree patients should not be refused
care based solely on their vaccination
status but any decisions to refuse care
should be made through thorough and
thoughtful consideration of the medical
ethics to which physicians are held and
for which mechanisms are in place uh for
this review by the board of medicine
altogether again we appreciate the
sponsor's intent of the bill we feel
that it's important to allow for our
state's health care providers to
continue to make these ethical decisions
based on the current statute of the law
and with that i'm happy to answer any
questions and thank you for your time
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so and goodbye to our
guests
if the current statute
addresses the problem
that that this
uh
bill or hb 1003 is is trying to to
address
then why have patients been denied
as we've heard today
treatment for vaccination status um
as we've also heard i mean
we don't know all of the details of all
these different cases and if they've
been brought to the board of medicine
and reviewed and investigated that is
the current recourse um
you know for folks to be able to
resolve some of these issues
follow up thank you
so
as the previous uh person who testified
stated she did complain to the board and
it took 12 years for one position that
she had complained against and there was
no
follow-up to her as to to know whether
or not there was any recourse
for what had happened
and if she recently has got a problem
with having a family member refused to
get treatment
what what is the recourse is the is
there no recourse
seems like there is not
as as i've stated the recourse would be
to go to the board of medicine i don't
speak for the board of medicine and
their processes um individuals you know
are still allowed to go to to seek other
treatment providers um if one particular
treatment provider made a decision not
to treat that patient
you know they are responsible for that
decision and
through that res that recourse of the
board of medicine individuals always are
available or always are allowed to go
and seek treatment elsewhere
okay thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
it's
if i understand right you are saying
that a provider who does not who does
not treat you
if they refuse you don't happen even if
you report them you don't know
what what the result is
and
that sounds like you also don't get any
kind of
help while you're being denied treatment
do you agree
that
this proposed bill
is mentioning
do you agree with the people who have
said this bill is actually by citing
it's actually should be referring to
facilities rather than providers
so in that case are you a representative
of facilities so can you explain how
this would affect facilities
i i should have clarified when i when i
began my testimony i realized that there
that this this bill does not
specifically address the physician
statute um but
because there was reference to
healthcare providers i did feel that it
was appropriate for at least to come and
just
speak to i think the physician's
perspective on this but i don't know if
i can answer your question specifically
because i don't speak necessarily for
the facilities
thank you representative leon thank you
mr chairman and thank you for coming to
answer questions on this today
my question is about oversight over the
complaints process at the board of
medicine is there any oversight on the
top-level basis about types of complaint
or anything else that's provided to any
legislative body or
to any of anything with anyone within
the legislature
thank you for the question i don't
represent the board of medicine i don't
know if i can speak to that but i
certainly would encourage you to reach
out to to them uh and ask that same
question
sing no further questions thank you for
coming before us today
journal recognizes once again dr gary
york
thank you chairman pearson and all the
members of the committee present today
like others on the committee i was a
little surprised that this was put forth
for possible legislation
as a physician and other physicians have
remarked is this is this a problem
i mean is this is this happening
and i felt like
posing the question to myself out loud
would you believe
this is happening in new hampshire
not knowing the answer suspecting that
it is and representative
cushman
clearly gave
testimony that it is happening
now i must admit that i'm not a little
confused as to where this legislation
belongs uh in the main i believe that
patients need this
protection
um it's it's sort of a proactive bill in
a way in that patients really need
to know that they have the right to be
treated and not refused
for medical treatment
um
people have mentioned maybe this belongs
on the bill of rights uh patient rights
uh and and i
not knowing much about how laws are made
and enacted i would agree with that
to to my limited knowledge of that
but the question of where it belongs
can be sorted out by people much smarter
than i am
but i do strongly believe it belongs it
belongs somewhere because
as others have stated there's
discrimination going on
and i think it i need to clarify that it
needs to be written down somewhere that
the public can access this information
that this woman who gave brave testimony
with her family that she
was denied
treatment
but she wasn't aware that she was able
to bring that to the board of medicine
i think if so this were somewhere
in the public record that yes as a
patient
this is your right
and that you have you have a right not
to be
discriminated solely on your vaccination
status
and i would agree that yes this is
appropriate to include all vaccinations
um
i'll take questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
in lieu of since you know we
as a person on your side on this issue i
appreciate your coming and testifying
and so do you have any suggestions
because you know people really want to
make other people safe as well as
themselves so do you have any
recommendations
that that ought to be part of public
health to try to be an
alternative to this
not so great way of protecting with
vaccines
i think
what i would throw
forth as someone who's not vaccinated is
please lose your unfounded fear of
people who are unvaccinated
we're not full of germs we don't have
any
special evil superpowers to infect
others it is clearly known
that the vaccinated and the unvaccinated
are equally
able to transmit the disease
perhaps
if you're vaccinated and you have the
assumption that oh i can go and
gather and travel and and meet with a
lot of people
because i've been vaccinated well that's
not practicing safe distancing but
i'm getting off topic here but um i i
think
i think
i would i would recommend that people
lose the unfounded fear of the
unvaccinated as someone who
might be someone to fear i mean we're
just regular people i mean there's no
difference between me and anyone in the
room
as far as risk of spreading disease
depending on what your habits are
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
do you do you think that these uh
statute this should also be in the
statutes that regulate the providers
such as
nurse practitioners practitioners
physicians
dentists psa pa p a s's etc
i think it should include all health
providers yes
thank you and um
there was a question before that comment
on like telehealth could that be could
that be an accommodation for
a way to
[Music]
if you if you uh
a telehealth could accommodate someone
so that you wouldn't have to refuse
treating a patient so that would be an
acceptable
accommodation for sure
thank you doctor
do i see
representative king
thank you mr chairman and i'll take a
stab at this question um
because i think i'm as confused as you
are um
the
it sounds like there's two problems and
um and the bill addresses one of them
but there's still another problem
um
so people are being
from the testimony i've heard this
afternoon
it sounds like people are being
discriminated for not having vaccines
and
people that have actually known about
how to
file those complaints
either don't know what the outcome is or
nothing comes of it
or both
is is that where your confusion is as
well
uh
not having been on the board of medicine
in new hampshire or any other board of
medicine i'm not fully aware of the
practice that they that they do in
evaluating complaints against physicians
or health care providers so
um
i guess to answer your question i am
confused because um i do not know it is
known i do not know
thank you
thank you seeing no further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you next we will call from
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee from record paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations for the new hampshire hospital
association representing all our
hospitals the new hampshire hospital
association is in strong opposition to
house bill 1003. this bill prohibits
healthcare providers from refusing to
care provide care or services based on
patient vaccination status this bill in
our opinion is simply not necessary let
me be very clear and direct hospitals do
not refuse services or care to anyone
period in addition from a technical
perspective the statute being amended is
confusing rsa 151 21b is actually the
home care client bill of rights which is
not specific to health facilities per se
it also has nothing to do with
individual providers it is unclear what
what the sponsor of the bill was
intending by the term health care
provider licensed or registered
as it is that is also confusing to us
concerning health care clinicians new
hampshire registers med techs only so it
is not clear why this term is being used
new hampshire licensed clinicians that
provide direct care to patients rsa 151
as was discussed last week when another
bill
house bill 1044 sponsored by
representative mclean was heard is
related to health facilities only no
individual provider falls under this
statute
and all the examples that i wrote down
by the sponsor we're talking about
individual providers pediatricians
dermatologists etc
i
i also would like to emphasize that
hospitals treat all patients regardless
of their ability to pay and certainly
they are agnostic when it comes to
vaccination status the current
hospitalization data bears this out with
nearly 35 percent of those in the
hospital as we sit here today with covin
19 are not vaccinated i would argue that
this fact clearly demonstrates that this
bill is misplaced and unnecessary
further the emergency medical treatment
and labor act it's a national federal
rule law amtala requires hospitals with
emergency departments to provide a
medical screening examination to any
individual who comes to the emergency
department and requests such an
examination and prohibits hospitals with
emergency departments from refusing to
examine or treat regardless of their
ability to pay
on behalf of our hospital our health
care heroes who have been tirelessly and
compassionately caring for patients with
covet for the last two years i ask you
to reject this unnecessary bill and
honestly i find this offensive to our
health care heroes
please stand with me and the
overwhelming majority of new hampshire
citizens that support our health care
heroes and find this bill in expedient
to legislate thank you and i'm happy to
provide any answers to questions that
you make questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much
and as a person as a person who lives
here i'm very grateful to hear that the
hospital policy is that you are not
discriminated for your uh vaccination
status however
this bill is supposed to cover
many kinds of facilities
do you speak for them too no i
represent the hospitals okay thank you
representative i'm sorry sorry i didn't
it's not related to representative gay's
question i just wanted to make one more
statement but i i want to take questions
first sorry
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
i'm often reminded about uh why law
exists in the first place and it's
usually because of the misbehaviors so
you mentioned the healthcare heroes and
i'm sure
i'm sure they're
i'm sure there's a lot of them out there
what do we do about the ones that are
misbehaving as we heard from testimony
today there are people that are being
denied health care whether it's
at a
local provider or wherever it is but
and we've also heard that
the k the the method of them bringing
that to the light is
not really being
handled very well
what is what are your what's your take
on that thank you for the question so
again this bill as has been stated by
many um
very experienced um legislators on this
committee um this is amending rsa 151
and again i don't think it
it's not the patient bill of rights is
151 21. um and what i wanted to say is
that a statement was made that the
hospitals are currently violating the
patient bill of rights and i take
offense to that as well they are not um
a
individual that is a child always has a
patient
excuse me a caregiver or a parent that's
allowed to come in if they are in the in
the hospital so the visitor policies are
staff
but what you're referring to again
talking about pediatricians and and the
like though that falls under the board
of medicine or the appropriate cl
clinical board 151 is the licensing
health facilities licensing board um and
there is um i mean i think
representative gay said the um the
recourse is the department of hhs if a
fa violation is
is filed with the department um the
hospital could um they could their
license is in jeopardy that's really
ultimately um what this
what 151 is all about
so i think this is really an oplc office
professional licensing and certification
question
and if that's the intent that is
different and again i
as mr padmore said i also do not
represent the the boards um so i think
that's a question for the boards
any other questions
oh yeah i think i said what i wanted to
yeah
did you speak to the point you didn't
speak to when you said you were think i
later did i think i did the other point
the other note i wrote um is that um
relative to um
determination of um
of how i mean this is well beyond my
scope by but representative knurk raised
this i think relative to um
organ transplants et cetera they have
ethical committees and i suspect both of
these
wonderful
retired physicians sat on those at one
point there are ethical there are ethics
committees that um make those
determinations relative to organs um
etc
when when a um where you end up on that
transplant list so um i just um that is
really um referencing when you started
talking about that i was i just made a
note about the ethics committees that
hospitals
engage in those decisions those
discussions
thank you so much yeah welcome thank you
and the chair now recognizes kelly
potenza from rochester new hampshire who
wishes to speak
in support of the bill
so i drove here today because i didn't
know how many people were going to speak
in support of this and i have been
working tirelessly for
months
as in a sense of
a kind of a patient advocate in a i've
been working with southern new hampshire
medical i've been working with cottage
hospital um on behalf of patients that
in a sense are getting discriminated
against so
in all due respect the reason why we
have to do things sometimes is because
yes there's tons of heroes out there but
there are people that are breaking it
and so
where is the recourse currently so if if
we make a
you know a complaint where does that go
unfortunately if that complaint doesn't
go anywhere and it doesn't have
money tied to it nothing's going to
change
and so even this legislation
what happens what happens if somebody's
refused i can give you four dentists
right now i can give you four
pediatricians out on the seacoast that
are denying um parents to have they
don't want their kids because they're
not vaccinated and so this is way more
than cobot 19. this has been going on in
new hampshire for quite some time it's
basically like we don't want you so this
is the whole beauty of of medical
freedom right you have the choice to
take a vaccine and by the way cover 19
is not a vaccine
it is let's just be crystal clear about
that okay it is an experimental um gene
therapy injection
that is not fda approved it's only been
approved for emergency authorized use
and the only reason why this has had to
come up is because of the coven 19
injection
right now i i don't know if you guys
realize this but
the veterans hospitals here in the state
of new hampshire are not you you cannot
get help if i can give you names if you
want them i'll send it out to if these
people are okay with it because we're
trying to find them other practitioners
that will treat them because if they
don't have
the coven 19 injection they're not
allowed to get any treatment from the va
hospitals right now in new hampshire
that's going on and so let's talk about
what southern new hampshire medical is
doing or how about dartmouth-hitchcock
these hospitals all have systems they're
called epic and serna and all of that so
when you are let's say you're in a
life-threatening situation and you go to
the hospital
they're going to ask all of this
information about you so let's say
that's me
they're going to ask you know all of
these you know personal information
the sixth line on a medical record right
now
for um southern new hampshire medical in
nashua is
covet you know basically it says covet
19 vaccination or they'll say it says
patient is not vaccinated for cover 19.
how does that have anything to do with
anything are they asking about mmr are
they asking about flu are they asking
about anything else which those are
vaccines that have gone through this
rigorous testing years and years they're
not so why would that be on somebody's
medical record that right there is
discrimination i can tell you right now
my girlfriend's father was killed at
southern new hampshire medical because
he
was not vaccinated he went in there to
get oxygen and they literally left him
there to die for one week they didn't
feed him they didn't give him iv fluids
he was like yeah did they treat him
he was there he was admitted but they
didn't give him any treatment this is
going on in new hampshire unfortunately
um it shouldn't have to be necessary
right they're right it shouldn't have to
be necessary but we actually live in a
world right now when something is so
polarized and out of control that we
actually have to have legislation like
this we have to pass laws like this but
it needs to have teeth because if
somebody's denied any of this
they need to they need to lose a license
and they need to pay big time
so that's where i'm at any questions
any questions from the committee
representative gay
thank you for
thank you thank you
uh would the without naming anybody with
the man who died happen to have a
daughter who's a chiropractor in salem
thank you very much yes so you know
about her okay
there you go and there will be a lawsuit
forthcoming soon
representative
thank you madam chairman
and thank you for taking my pseudo
question um
would you believe i'm no longer confused
thank you for your testimony
well thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
very much
now
is the prime sponsor interested in
working on an amendment for this this is
not an early bill
but it does have to be out the door by
the middle of march
um
representative merchant indicated
interest to help you um a couple more
and
that you can find and uh
you can pick them it's your bill i mean
it's our bill but it's yours
and just let me know who's on the group
and we'll be looking forward to
getting something in due course
thank you thank you mr chairman
and this concludes the hearing on house
bill
and we'll give it about two or three
minutes just to stretch and look around
and whatever
any cookies cookies
um
right
there you go
of course
i don't know
oh
there's no recourse
really bad
oh gosh i wish i had some water too
sometimes i am sometimes it's gone
when i went because of this fall i had
i went into the hospital
and it was determined that i probably
had a concussion
um as soon as the nurse found out i was
not vaccinated and i told her it was a
decision by my doctor
yeah but you know she found out and um
so
they were supposed to check on me every
15 minutes
they left me
by myself
i was shivering i was crying after a
while i finally got off the gurney thing
got my coat and put it on
and then finally when somebody came from
radiology over an hour later
night
she has some other patients with the
same neurological conditions
and she said they all did really poorly
right right and you guys just
put it off as long as you can
you know
is
needs to be
so here i am with the concussion
around on one foot trying not to fall
over
you know whatever
um
you know i didn't even think of
complaining to any medical awards or
anything about what happened
it's not going to make a difference
i don't like to go to hospitals anywhere
too much time in them
oh
uh
gary could you um
yeah yeah
yeah well
i actually had a case once where
the emergency surgeon that worked on me
did
and i said i'm serious
open the hearing on house bill 1099
prohibiting the department of health and
human services from acquiring vaccine
passports for services
prime sponsor representative teroshan
from atkinson
good afternoon and thank you mr chairman
and members of the health
human services and elderly affairs
committee
for the record my name is peter teroshan
i'm one of the state reps that
represents rockingham county district 14
which is the town of atkinson and
plaistow i'm here today to testify on
behalf of house bill 1099 as the prime
sponsor
1099 is an act prohibiting the
department of health and human services
from requiring vaccine passports for
service services
it's a pretty straightforward bill
it's designed to prevent discrimination
based on one's immunization status
vaccine status in my opinion is a
private medical it's private medical
information it should stay that way
lastly the department of health and
human services attempted to have public
hearings regarding the possibility of
establishing a passport mandate
this legislation if enacted in house
bill 1099 should prevent such a mandate
from be
from becoming created
again this is a very simple bill
and
it is designed to ensure that every
person has the natural essential
inherent right to a bodily integrity
free from any from any threat
or compulsion by government to accept
any immunization
accordingly no person may be
compelled to receive
an immunization
for covert 19 in order to secure or
receive access
in any public facility public benefit or
any other public service from the state
of new hampshire or any other political
subdivision
including but not limited to counties
cities towns school districts etc
i ask that the committee fine house bill
1099 autopass
with that
i will be glad to take any questions
that the committee may have in regard to
this bill
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question
i just as a point of clarification
because we have had a number of bills
that deal with the same subject matter
want to be sure that this bill is not in
any way in opposition to
the
department issuing vaccine cards or
documentation for those people who want
them and need them
no this bill doesn't does in no way
speak to doing that but it does prevent
the department from requiring a
mandatory passport i just wanted to be
sure that they they would still be
available
yes yes this this would not affect that
anyway thank you thanks for the question
representative soloway
i don't think it's on yet
oh more power to you
better here i think i'm
i think i'm dead
oh there we go
thank you
oh don't take it away representative
i apologize representative
in line 12
you specify
that an individual has been vaccinated
against
covid
what would you like to do when the next
epidemic comes around
are you going to pass another bill
identifying that
health to the threat of the community
and then another one and another one or
would you like perhaps to create a more
general statement
to uh push forward your intent that no
one should ever have to produce a
passport thank you
thank you representative for the
question and when i did go to ols to
draft it i
tried to intentionally keep it open to
just covered and they added the 19 in
there so if you want to do an amendment
or the committee does i'd be
you know i
think that would be a good
uh amendment to strike that so that it
does cover any future variations that
may develop thank you
representative canark
actually kind of
go a little broader
and that is
should it even say covert 19 should just
say
has been vaccinated
period we just spent a long time talking
about a bill that had to do with you
know all vaccinations or just token 19
and of course the names may be totally
different it may not be anything to do
with covet
and i don't know whether it should be
broadened to any vaccines i i kind of
doubt that the department would ever
deny care anyway but i can appreciate
your antenna making sure it doesn't
happen should have even broader
i i wouldn't uh object to that
again the intent is to protect all new
hampshire citizens in their private
medical
information and to ensure that they're
we don't discriminate and create a class
those who are vaccinating those that
aren't and you know i can't predict
what's around the corner but you know
uh mother nature the way she is
you know there'll be something else down
the road and it may or may not be a
covet type um
yeah so
the more broad we could make it and the
more we can cover
any uh
future possibilities i would be open to
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
we have a long history in this country
of having a separation with the federal
to the state level we don't want the
federal government telling the states
what to do however this bill basically
tells us the cities and all the local
municipalities up with what they should
do
is that my reading this bill
thank you for the question
representative and and i would say no
what what this does say though is that
they can't again discriminate against
you
um with what your status is so
for example if the
local town or city wants to create a
um
you know an ordinance that you have to
wear a mask
in in town hall this wouldn't affect
that but it would
uh
prevent them from
discriminating against an individual in
any services they may provide
again on their their vaccination status
it's that simple
follow-up
no
no okay uh representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative trojan for taking the
question
am i right to read this that it's only
prohibiting discrimination or separation
based on an irreversible invasive
medical procedure as opposed to those
easily reversible ones like masking or
other temporary measures
all right
if you look at the the title it it
involves vaccine passports so
it doesn't say
you know
masking passport so no that's not
included in here that's why i brought it
up in the case of a local
governing board that wants to
enact a mass mandate
it wouldn't prevent that
follow-up and follow-up is that then
this is preventing um this is basically
looking to that irreversible choice of
being vaccinated and if the science ends
up shifting then it then is this
intended so that people
don't have to take one even if maybe six
months or a year later they're no longer
important
yes and as a matter of fact um
you know one of the
the points that i didn't make that i had
written down is that
we're learning more and more about
the uh
the code with the new strains that are
coming out
and we're compiling data in regard to
the transmission of covert in
relationship to whether you're
vaccinated or not and we're learning
as we go forward particularly with the
newest strains that
very similar
numbers of people are transmitting
the new strains whether they're
vaccinated not doesn't seem to make much
difference
so you know i'm hopeful that the
the newer strains are
are going to be um
less um
catastrophic to people they certainly
seem to be but irregardless
i guess the point is that
i think as we look at
statistics and we look at them honestly
we're finding that the
[Music]
having a vaccine passport of mandate
isn't isn't what we thought it was going
to be in regard to
reducing the spread of the
disease disease so
the intent is to
and reinforce people's constitutional
rights and their right to
medical privacy in regard to their
vaccination status thanks for the
question thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
thank you representation
would it make any difference because
we're using the term passport but we
also want to return which
many of us are opposed to passports but
we don't want to stop
producing
proof of vaccination for the people who
would like to have one so
would you have any objection if
the wordsmithing somehow
uh
used
you know maybe i i don't have an answer
yet so i can't even make a proposal but
something about like you defined
passport in the ques in the statement
you define the passport as
proof uh but
in this case that's what it means but in
other cases as
uh
one other representative was asking how
do we retain the right to get a proof
but you use it in some cases as a
passport i know i'm going all over the
place i'm not quite sure exactly how to
address this but is that okay
to
to define words as long as the intent is
exactly the same
well
i i think the way that i have it written
is it's pretty clear that in regard to
not requiring
you know
somebody to have to use the word
passport this other word you could use
to not basically intent on this is to
ensure that we don't require
uh
somebody be vaccinated to receive
services in the state nowhere in the in
the language does it say that you can't
uh
provide um
you know vaccination um
cards for people that choose to be
vaccinated indeed we're doing currently
i don't see
the language prohibiting that and but i
do believe that should be done on a
volunteer basis so if you want to have
that done and that information available
to you
you will be able to if i don't want to
have it
i would have the right under this not to
have it you know i'd want to be put on a
registry
of people
where i'm segregated by again my vaccine
choices
i hope i answered some of the questions
thank you i agree representative weber
would you believe and would you believe
that i hope that representative gay
believes that
i believe that this language still
permits me to get the documentation i
want on a voluntary basis
if i need it without any interference in
that it is only the requirement broadly
as an access to services that is
prohibited here
i would believe
thank you
we do that here representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman
thanks for taking this question
um having read through the medical
freedom and immunizations
act i guess to be called it's already
fairly broad and you are adding um
you are adding that
it will not prevent people from
accessing department programs benefits
or services
i assume that means department of health
and human services
so i'm just thinking about the intent of
this bill
and
what services
might the department keep people from
accessing are we talking about things
like medicaid or tanf or
what what services are you trying to
prevent people from being discriminated
against
thank you representative for the
question and um if you look at the bold
print it does refer to the department of
health and human services shall not
require a vaccine passport as a
condition of eligibility for any uh
for or access to department programs
benefits or services in this section
vaccine passports mean standard
standardized documentation that an
individual has been vaccinated against
so
it's i think pretty broad but broad so
that it includes any and all
services that they provide so i'm not
specific to to just a handful because i
want to
keep that open for any and all services
that
may be
obtained
okay thank you
representative weber
thank you and again for purposes of
clarity
i'm wondering because the existing
language already says
no person may be compelled to receive an
immunization for coven 19 in order to
secure receiver access any public
facility public benefit or any public
service from the state of new hampshire
or any of its political subdivisions
does that not already cover all of the
services provided by the department of
health
that's part number one and part number
two
is the issue
not the passport but the requirement of
the vaccination itself
which is what the first half of the bill
speaks to
aren't we
simply
stating
the same thing in different terms and
confusing it by using two different
terminologies
for the same concept which is my
understanding is that your concept is
you don't want anybody
based on their vaccine their cova
vaccine choices
to be denied benefits well the statute
already says that doesn't it
well it i believe it does to some extent
but i want to
this legislation is intended to
make sure it includes the department of
health and human services because let's
face it they're
one of the
probably the biggest uh state
uh government agencies
that has tremendous power to dictate if
they so choose and to
make rule making so this wants to click
what
the intent is is to
clarify
that
the department
doesn't require
um
you know a vaccine requirement
and um and i guess the reason why i
wanted to put that into language was
because the
as i mentioned
earlier last year they did
start having public hearings
with many people showing up concerned
that they were
interested in creating
um a mandate so that this is to clarify
and to
uh prevent
that happening in the future follow-up
representative weber
thank you and again
in in the interest of clarity and
simplicity
if i believed that
such language was necessary which i
personally don't but if i believed it
did
instead of introducing the concept of
vaccine passports into a statute that
was written about vaccinations
would it not be more efficient and just
as
conclusive
to say
no person may be compelled to re
to receive secu secure receiver access
any public facility any public benefit
or any public service
from the state of new hampshire
or
the department of health and human
services or any subdivision of
services probably needs to go to the end
of the line but
if you added dhhs into that list of
people
who this is not includes and is not
limited to wouldn't that accomplish the
same thing without introducing
the apples and oranges problem into the
statute
thank you for the question
representative it may i'm not an
attorney i consulted with all us
obviously when we drafted this and made
it pretty clear what my my intent was
with the legislation um could it be done
in a way perhaps
um
you know that's something certainly
you all as a committee can decide if you
think the language is
sufficient if not i'm certainly open to
an amendment as long as it keeps the
intent which i hope i've
communicated what the intent is here and
if the committee agrees i hope you
consider otp you know i certainly would
be again open to amendments if you
believe that would streamline and
be a little clearer i certainly would
could support that
i believe i saw representative
merchant's hand yes
you did mr chairman but uh
representative weber
asked the question very eloquently thank
you
represent representative snow
thank you mr chairman wow
the first time i heard the word
passport used in this context was to fly
on an airplane
and
you know later i guess there's been some
conversation to get at a cruise ship or
anything like that where it's going to
leave the country and have to have a
passport
now i haven't dug into this i haven't
exploded i don't know many facts about
it but if i have a card that says i've
been vaccinated
is that the same as having that passport
and can i get on an airplane and can i
do all the other things or does that
then require some other step to be taken
area and secondly
does that mean only the department and
state-run facilities and probably
subcontractors from that state
but private businesses could require a
passport or at least certification
of vaccination status under this law
thank you
representative for the question and i
think the reason we use the term
passport is because that's been vented
about quite a bit now
throughout the last couple of years
and you know you do need a passport to
enter other foreign countries
and um
there's many
uh organizations out there that are
looking to require
what they're terming a vaccination
passport
to to get services in other areas
so
but to answer your question regard to
private industry no it doesn't it
doesn't discuss private entity in here
it's pretty specific the state of new
hampshire any
uh political subdivision towns cities
and so forth so no it doesn't prevent
that
in the answer to that part of the
question
okay
i believe representative shapiro no wave
off
okay thank you representative teroshan
thank you mr chair and committee and
enjoy the rest of the day
the chair recognizes frederick
no last name but i bet he has one
hello
hi
my name is frederick bonilla
oh sorry excuse me my name my name is
fredrik bonilla i'm here
basically just to represent the people i
really felt the calling because my
friend wanted to come
um
i'm not really
i'm not
really
understanding
why people
are trying to agree
on the killing and murdering of other
people's
family members
and loved ones just because
they're not their family
it's one of the saddest things
that i've seen
that people want to agree
people want to be in line seeing people
falling dead in line
to receive something that you guys know
very well has been killing
our family members and our children
i don't understand
how
you have states like new york city
and california
that are going to actually anyone who's
ever been through
any type of discrimination should not
even think about
this bill i mean
to think about
allowing people to continue to inject
our family members for their death
we've seen it with famous people we've
seen it not with famous people we have
people walking out all the time the cdc
themselves put it on their website that
if you get the injection that your own
immune system is 97
stronger than if you get the injection
at 94 i think it lowers your
immune system as soon as you get it in
there
who wants to do that they said it
themselves ted talk 2014
mr gates already talked about killing
all of us but people want to sit around
and think that that's not true they want
to point fingers he said it himself it
was out of his mouth at a ted talk
and here we are how many years later
exactly what he said he was going to do
on that ted talk is exactly before us
and then they cause it and then they're
going to think that after causing people
to suffer and go through all these
things and then putting them out of work
because of something they created that
you're not going to give them the help
that they need that is not america
you're not representing america at all
that is not i'm not even from america
but the things that have been happening
and i take pride for my america the real
america the people this isn't the most
disgusting thing that i've ever seen in
my life
for everything that i said from my
country tis of the all the way to the
end ever since you guys took that out of
our schools
and thank you for those who fought for
our country because it's because of you
that we're free to this day and by far
why would anybody in their children
allow that to happen our freedom's
getting taken away daily and that's it
starts with this stupid thing that kills
our people
i think that's it
thank you sir this is really compelling
and heartfelt appreciates it you would
come today
thank you share that and welcome america
i hope we treat you well
yes please do not
allow people to continue to die because
of the sake of people in power that have
the ability to do that
somebody has to speak for us
and we put you guys in there for that
specific reason
don't ever let us down ever please and
you better spread it to the rest of them
too because that's all we have
and and
that's all we have right now
is america the great
don't let it fall for nobody
you sir we've got several people i'm
glad you're one of them today
could i now call up bruce and chester
please to the speaker's table
she keeps saying
who's sad
thank you you're gonna get it you keep
coming i'll get it i'm sorry
give me a second
all right it's okay
that is exactly
what we're trying to protect
we're trying to protect that right in
new hampshire you all know
that the federal we have taken money now
from the federal government that has
vaccine passports and central registries
and this robust response to covid
the bottom line is
we need our representatives in new
hampshire to protect new hampshire's
citizens
when we've gotten to the point now in
our in our state that we don't trust our
federal government to protect us anymore
we don't trust our all the new hampshire
hospital association dhhs all these
different
levels of
big corporation
many of you may not even remember the ma
the ma bell controversy with monopolies
but bottom line is that's what's
happened with our health care system
that's what's happened with the health
care system and discrimination is
happening it's happening more and more
often and yes do the unvaccinated need
to become a protected class or we need
some kind of protection well once upon a
time we didn't need protection for
sexual identity
we didn't need protection
against i remember
the the feminist movement
back then
we needed protection so we got it why
did we need protection because our
government and our media and our
corporate people had begin our
corporations had begin to discriminate
now is the time to stop the
discrimination all levels race
religion
uh sexual orientation
vaccination status unfortunately
vaccination status knee is real
because it has been politicized we need
to respond
thank you very much for your time and
i'm open to questions
one question by betty gay thank you
thank you very much and may i assume
that not only you but the man before you
both support this bill wholeheartedly
thank you for the question
representative gay um
i would like to be able to say
that we don't need this bill
i would like to be able to say we have
enough government already
unfortunately
when
government starts putting
the
power of their own
ideas above
the responsibility or the representation
of the people then we need protection so
yes i truly support this bill but only
because
it's basically to stop
big government
my opinion
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair recognizes uh kelly potenza
so i'm not i know i'm not supposed to be
able to ask questions but i'm i'm pretty
sure that this um amend rsa 141 c1a
has to do with the bill that was passed
last session which is hb 220 correct
okay
i spent a lot of time on that hb 220. so
this is the this is the reason why we're
here unfortunately
hb 220 really didn't protect anybody you
know it was
we spent a lot of time in a lot of
testimony
thousands of people were all about this
because they wanted to be protected
so if you look at unh this is a great
this is a great example
unh did absolutely the polar opposite of
this because then again hb 220 they were
compelling vaccinations for their
students denying religious exemptions
and then also for all their faculty and
staff well based upon how this was
currently written without having this in
here they should have been protected but
there was no teeth to it so then what do
you have to do you have to go spend
thousands of dollars to hire a lawyer
you have to pull your kids out of that
school i mean it's crazy
and it really shouldn't be just for
public because there's no real private
business in the state
if that was the case then i could just
go open up my own little bagel shop
tomorrow and then i wouldn't have to pay
anything to the to the state or anything
like that it doesn't work like that but
we're not going to go private and
probably public because that's i know
that that can't happen
but when it comes to adding this line in
uh we have to add that in
and this is the reason why
it has to do with vaccine registry right
so this goes back years we've been
wanting to build this for a long time in
new hampshire and we've taken in
federal money
once
twice now we've probably taken in
federal money three times millions and
millions of dollars to build this
vaccine registry that's actually never
been built which is really creating uh
in a sense a um
the haves and the have-nots it's
creating uh an online
vaccine passport system
so
if we just look at our state
constitution and our bill of rights
this is beautiful
article 2b right of privacy this right
here protects us
so if we strip away all of these laws
this is what it comes down to an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent
wow that's all we need right there
and that should negate everything else
here but we have to continue to because
we're not really following the law of
the land we have to continue to
put layers upon layers upon layers from
hb 220 which becomes law that doesn't
ever that doesn't really protect anybody
and now we have to put this in because
yes
dhhs is an overreaching organization and
i'm sure they're going to be coming up
here to testify and oppose this and blah
blah blah but this is where we are so
no one in any way shape or form should
have to show anything to
go out to eat
actually or go to a museum because you
know the is it the courier i think it is
in manchester that's now requiring a
vaccine passport isn't that wonderful
do they take state funds yes they do but
they're still considered a private
business let's strip away every single
dime that they've received from state
funds grants and all of that okay
because they're requiring that so this
is what is we've got to have bills
that's wonderful but there has to be
teeth to it we have to hold these people
accountable
so
that's where i'm at thank you so much
would you take a question sure
i don't see what but thank you for
coming back
the chair now recognizes dr j corson
from manchester
to support this bill and welcome back
and let's make sure we stick to this
bill we're not going down either mechtum
or any other thing that we will do again
but we're not doing it today it's just
this i understand chairman yes sir that
wasn't addressed to you no no
anybody who is listening
i find it odd that i'm sitting here
again i had went back took care of some
patients in manchester came back
but specifically to testify again
and i
don't you find
on both sides of the aisle don't you
find it odd that we're sitting here
discussing whether
we're gonna discriminate against
somebody based upon their vaccine
uh status
whether they have a they'll have to
provide a piece of paper that says that
they
were vaccinated or not in order to
receive what they're entitled to but
in the state
two years ago if you think back in your
mind two years ago
or three years ago would you have ever
thought that we would be
excuse me we have a point of order yes
uh representative weber
thank you representative please speak to
the bill directly
thank you representative
so
this bill
is asking
that we don't
require
a vaccine passport
or
the proof of a vaccine in order to
receive
services
in this state
and it's and what i was saying is it's a
shame that we have to even ask that to
even have to have a bill like this
but we need to support a bill like this
because if we don't
we'll go down the same
rabbit hole
that
required vaccines required mass and
other things
that we've seen over the last two years
will emerge and we'll say wow we didn't
think that was possible this will
prevent that
and that's why i'm in support of it was
that succinct enough representative
that was magnificent thank you thank you
thank you chairman that's all i know the
side of the aisle agrees yeah
any questions for the doctor
thank you for the time thank you
and the chair recognizes catherine
i bet you know frederick right
thank you
i just want to thank um
you all for this bill
and
i struggle with anxiety also like that
little girl so it made me cry
and um i have a wrongful conviction out
of rockingham county
and there needs to be a bill to protect
inmates and people on parole and people
that are in
institutions
i absolutely do not consent to this
wicked vaccine it is poisonous it has
caused a genocide in this country
it is caused according to vare's
v-a-e-r-s
uh reporting site which is only one
percent
of the instant deaths have been over 25
000 instant deaths in this country it is
unacceptable this vaccine is killing
people
and
i do not consent to it
i don't recognize my country anymore
i see videos on youtube of people
being
arrested for going to burger king for a
hamburger
because they didn't have a vaccine
passport to get into burger king and
they're being loaded into vans and this
is happening in america and i don't
recognize my country anymore
i also want that on the record because
you don't trade your freedom for your
safety
safety is a guide of tyranny
and you don't cancel the constitution or
replace it with other
laws that's not what our forefathers
died for and gave their lives for
people fought and died for basic
freedoms in this country
and we're of a different generation it's
not
you know we didn't fight and die it was
our grandfathers that did it
but they did it and they did it so that
we would have freedom now
and we need to have freedom we have to
have more freedom in this country
because it makes my heart sad to see
the changes in our country that i see
happening
and
i meditate and i pray and
i have a very strong spiritual
connection so i can see through a lot of
this and i've done a lot of independent
research and people are under a spell
that needs to be broken this yolk needs
to be broken it's not healthy for mental
health or physical health
it's really at the end of the day about
you know the elite getting money in
power and people dying
um catherine we we're getting to the end
of the day here and we want to be sharp
and listen to everything i'm sorry i
just wanna i just appreciate it i
appreciate this bill i'm thankful for
this bill because
um i get services for
um
like um
you know ssi and things so
i don't want to be discriminated against
ever
i don't think anyone should be
discriminated against for their health
reasons or the color of their skin or
their or whatever the reason is no one
should be discriminated against and so i
want to thank you all
for listening to me
um i apologize because i'm new at this
but i just won't say what was on my
heart i want to live in a free country
you've done a good job really thank you
i'm going to ask if you would take a
question from yes sir
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony and for taking my
question
uh speaking about the correctional
facilities in new hampshire
um while you were there was it while a
vaccine was available for cobia 19 and
did they try to okay i wasn't there at
that time but i've
experienced
horrors there i've been treated and
abused terribly there
and i was charged wrongfully i was
entrapped by the police
14 years ago i've had no justice in
rockingham county even after filing
affidavit after affidavit legal filing
after legal filing
and we need to protect bodily autonomy
i've been upgrading
catherine we're gonna thank you for
coming um i just want to protect other
people i hear you and frederick too and
thank you both for coming and i hope
yeah the next time you go into burger
king it's going to be a great six i'm
not going to go into a burger king in
new york city well i wouldn't either but
anyway um
for a lot of reasons i don't want that
to come here
yeah i want i'm born here raised here
i'm 41 years old catherine we're going
to move on because we've got a clock
that's biting us
but thank you both so much for coming
and i'm going to ask abby rogers and
anne-marie mccurry
to come up
and
good afternoon
representative peterson members of the
committee i'm abby rogers legislative
liaison for dphs and i'm here with ann
marie mccurry bureau chief
section chief for immunization
and we are here to provide information
on hb 1099.
good afternoon chairman pearson and
members of the committee
currently rsa 141 c 1 a states that
other than the exemptions that are
specified under paragraph 2 and 3 no
person may be compelled to receive an
immunization for coven 19 in order to
secure receive or access any public
facility any public benefit or any
public service
the addition of this language as
proposed by hb 1099 is therefore
unnecessary
as documentation and vaccination in any
form is not required by the department
unless where code 19 vaccination
requirements is authorized under
paragraphs two and three
where covet 19 vaccination is required a
standardized documented vaccination is
necessary to serve as evidence of
vaccination
currently covet 19 vaccination records
are issued by providers who administer
vaccination to the recipient or the
recipient's guardian at the time of
vaccination
language of hb 1099 defines vaccine
passport to broadly include any
standardized documentation that an
individual has been vaccinated against
coven 19
if hb 1099 were to pass then the
department's standard documentation for
vaccination would be considered a
vaccine passport
thank you
i just wanted to add in that listening
to all the testimony today with the
concerns of the sponsor and also
um the really great point that
representative weber brought up about hb
220 sort of already encompassing the
concerns of the what the department can
offer um and does not does not offer a
vaccine passport has no intention of
doing that that it would be
if it was amenable to the sponsor maybe
the committee could consider
adding in on line six after new
hampshire
including but not limited to the
department of health and human services
and maybe considering
not including the rest of the
legislation
that would be something that we would
offer as something that would be
amenable and
helpful to the department and to clarify
the legislation thank you thank you
representative weber
if it were to read
any public service from the state of new
hampshire
the department of health and human
services
or any political subdivision of the
state in new hampshire and then
including but not limited to all those
things that it's already including but
not limited to
would that satisfy your concerns yes it
would thank you
no further questions
one further question
representative folsom with a further
question
thank you chairman pearson thank you for
taking my question
um my question is for those people that
have an exemption for religious reasons
rights of conscious
medical reasons would they receive an
identical
card
so that if they went someplace they
didn't have to pull out something else
so everyone would see
that oh you're one of them
so
would they be able to receive the same
identical card that everyone else gets
with
saying no no no vaccine but
she's approved
the department feels as though there are
multiple systems in place to
allow for those medical or religious
exemptions and those documents would be
a separate and distinct
card from any vaccination card because
those people would not be coming in for
vaccination hence would not
be eligible to receive a similar card
follow-up
if we
had to have something totally different
wouldn't that in a sense be
discriminatory towards those people that
don't have a vaccine it just is an open
door
thank you for the question um i'm not
sure if we're aware of anybody has
requested a non-vaccine card at the
department
or a card saying that they haven't been
vaccinated or they're they've chosen not
to have the vaccine is that correct um
okay i am
sorry no okay i i think it's not just
that but i'm thinking
if a card was issued
and someone wanted to go to a museum
that was not allowing people without a
vaccine but this person had
an excuse a allowable excuse
but they don't have a vaccine card
so boom they can't go in
um
would you provide an identical card so
it's proof that they've gone through the
process
and have that exemption
so that they could get into that museum
thank you for the question i actually
would think that that would be dependent
on what the regulations are of the
private business that's not accepting
them
i mean just to say that i think that if
you if they're saying that no one who
who cannot be vaccinated can enter then
that probably i don't know if they're
they would accept religious or medical
exemptions for entrants
i'm just looking at my card here and
holding up that other paper which says i
have a religious exemption and you know
what if i'm in a line of people
and i they all have a nice card like
this and i have this yellow paper with
the other words on it i might feel uh
that people are glaring at me if i'm
lucky and worse if i'm not so i would
you believe i
see the merit in what representative
folsom is saying
i would thank you representative weber
but isn't the distinction there
that the exemptions
are
either
medical in which case they're based on
a
medical provider's opinion
or
they are an exemption from a workplace
and the department doesn't have anything
to do at all currently
with
that and the issuing by the department
of such a card
would necessitate setting up
yet another registry is that true
yes that is correct we would not have
oversight um on
on
issuing any sort of card for that type
of that's not within our purview
representative canark
i think mine similar just would you
agree that this bill has nothing to do
with uh
private places or anything this has to
do only with
the dhhs and it says you can't uh ask
for a passport so there's no reason to
worry about an alternate passport would
you agree with that
so it's kind of off topic to do this
yes i would agree it's it's not um
we're here to talk about the the
language in the bill and i think those
questions although thank you for asking
them are not really under a purview
would you believe that despite my
respect for the representative it does
not just talk about dhhs but it talks
about other political subdivisions and
water districts
but what it's saying is you cannot ask
for it so why would we need to worry
about an alternative for something that
cannot be asked for
okay
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so from what i read
the only new part
of this bill is the bold part everything
else is current law
and
what the bold part
the uh
bold
text
seeks to do is just to make very clear
that the department of health and human
services
can't require some standardized form of
of
proof of vaccination in order for people
to obtain
dhhs governed benefits and services
so
is that correct
uh that's how i read the bill yes
follow-up follow-up
so um
therefore we're
um
i guess the
oh i guess that's it thank you thank you
representative gay
clarity on here
the brand new part the brand new part of
the bill
seems to be
and this is really a question because i
want to know if you think it does
can we just could we get the same
meaning out of it by skipping the new
words just adding in the
department of health and human services
on line six
and then that would be protecting
everybody that you cannot
need to show
proof
well it says
but on the first two lines it just says
you don't
need it so you wouldn't it would be
immaterial whether you had proof or not
yes we would agree with that yes so
follow-up question
who makes these you're on a roll who
makes these cards
it's just everybody who gave out
immunizations they gave cards is that
where all these various cards came from
sure so the
cdc
goes ahead and they issue the cards to
the state and the providers who are in
receipt of vaccine
so as vaccines are being delivered
they're also receiving the cards to go
alongside them so a vaccine
administrator would go ahead and have an
individual in front of them they would
fill out the record at the time they
would hand the record over to the person
who's receiving the vaccine or the
parent or guardian
and then the vaccine registry a
follow-up question yeah okay there's a
vaccine currently vaccine registry in
flux
so would the person giving the vaccine
be the one to enter it into whatever
system we have
which isn't settled yet
the the information would flow to the
new hampshire iis or the registry
only if a person does not elect to opt
out of that so if a person says no i
don't want my information to flow that
individual has the right to maintain
that information on their own accord
if the vaccine were received at a
pharmacy or provider's office where
there is an electronic medical record
the
medical record would show evidence of
the vaccination and the person would be
given the card so the person would be
able to obtain a copy of that record if
they were vaccinated in a provider
office or elsewhere where there is an
electronic medical record
and the opt out only applies to the
information
the iis the immunization immunization
system
where a person would elect to not have
that information flow over and that
information is controlled by the health
care provider whether the information
goes or not thank you
thank you for your question
thank you so much
and with that
close the hearing on house bill 1099 but
my sense is there could be
an amendment that some
folks might like to work on
representative weber
would you like anyone to help you i know
you can do it on your own but
if it's acceptable to people um
well we don't do that here for the most
part write minority reports because we
all agree on things
so i'm sure you're going to do it
mostly
i'm going to ask the committee not leave
we have one more item after this
absolutely so so representative webber
if anybody wants to whisper in her ear
on her walk that's up to you i i find it
extraordinary how you know
uh god spoke to uh
numbers of people simultaneously about
much the same thing i like that when it
happens uh in terms of this language
what's happening with my ear
yes
thank you mr chairman uh i'd be
interested in working on an amendment to
give that section of blossom teeth if
anyone else is interested
well
i don't know we could have two
amendments brought in or we could have
one
mother of all amendments brought in or
whatever representative weber that's
yours if you wish to do it or not
either one is good
would you like to try to work with the
representative or try to
bring forth what you had thought
we
if they're are on the same
if they're not on the same issue
we can always as a committee adopt two
amendments if we choose to do so
and ols will magically merge them into a
third amendment they're like that two
are approved by the committee
uh and
on you go from there
good
okay i'm going to close what was an
executive session you may not have heard
that earlier on 10.99
and now wait for it this is going to be
good the clerk is ready for this this is
use as many sheets as necessary and i
now open an executive session that we're
all going to have great fun with two
house bill 1390 and the chair proudly
turns it over to representative canark
who will walk us through
procedures like you've not necessarily
seen before
we've already exact this before we're
reopening and reopening
[Music]
okay get out 1390 if you have it you
weren't uh told we were going to so you
can look on with somebody else
what you are now
all right representative canark walk us
through the process please sir
okay here's the problem
uh we exact this
uh last week or the week before it was
last week i think it was this is the one
that has to do with language translation
services in telemedicine
the difficulty that we identified at
that time is that it was actually placed
in the wrong rsa
and john williams gave us guidance as to
which rsas to use we then i brought
forth an amendment which is the
amendment
uh if you don't have it don't worry o
two one zero and that was the one that
just placed it then the proper statutory
reference in new hampshire
so i was then of course because i made
the motion was supposed to write the
committee report as i sat down to write
the committee report being the
compulsive retired surgeon i am just for
kicks i went to check the cfr
citation uh that was in the original
bill and the amendment for the record we
executed on january 24th
right
and uh when i checked that i was a
little surprised because it was not the
right
uh code of federal regulation citation
it was citing uh cfr that had to do with
insurance exchanges that you know you
had to provide
translation and so on and so forth for
selling insurance had nothing to do with
care and this bill has to do with
providing care
so with that in mind i worked then with
the ols people
we found the proper cfr reference
and we inserted that
so this uh amendment that i've just
brought to you which is number zero four
zero nine h
is a replace all amendment
what it does it's precisely the same as
the one that we passed on the 24th
except that it corrects the
citations instead of 45 cfr one five
155.205 it's 92.101
and the other one is
0.102 because 101 has to do with
language access and 102 has to do with
deaf and hard of hearing so the issue is
it's an error in citation so i worked
with the clerk paul smith to sort out
how he corrected the correction would be
that we would i would move
reconsideration of our decision on the
bill from before
then please everybody votes yes that
means we can open that back up and
reconsider it
and i can do that because it was
unanimous so we're all over there and
then we will vote no on the otpa
with amendment zero two one zero which
we passed back on the 24th you can just
offer a next amendment yes exactly you
don't have to do no oh we don't even
have to say no so i will offer after
reconsider i thought reconsideration was
on the vote that we'd made when you
reconsider a vote you know
yeah so we will reconsider the vote
therefore we got this from the clerk
yeah that's right so we yeah i wanted to
streamline it because my poor beth is
going to pull her hair out but the
strand by strand but the issue is if we
reconsider that vote we can then
overturn our previous decisions so it's
no longer have a recommendation then i
will move the amendment we pass the
amendment then we'll remove otpa we all
agreed with this bill as unanimous it's
just simply to correct an error in
citation
so that's what this is all about it's a
little complicated and you may wish that
i hadn't checked it but it was we didn't
want to get into law incorrectly the
chair recognizes representative connerk
for a reconsideration motion yes i would
like to move reconsideration on the
motion that we passed on the 24th which
was on hb one three nine zero ought to
pass with amendment zero two one zero
and representative acton had seconded
originally so i will accept a second
from him
reconsideration having voted with the
prevailing side we can do that
when you're ready chair okay
we want to vote yes we're going to
reconsider
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
[Laughter]
oh no was he still here
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey absent representative king
yes representative cobalt absent
representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay representative snow yes
representative knight yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter
also yes representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant affirmative
representative pearson
yes
19-0
now the motion on the floor
is
um
the new internet yeah i know what it
is it's otp a with amendment zero two
one zero
no we have to vote down that's what i
mean that's what i'm talking about what
the previous motion was otp a with
amendment zero two one zero that needs
to be voted down now we'd now have to do
itl on that or no that was a that was an
otpa we don't vote on itl we're now
reconsidering that vote we're saying we
do not vote for it so a no vote will
kill
the mistake yes the previous vote was
just shall we think about it and do it
okay uh chair will recognize somebody to
make a motion um
reconsideration means we just re-vote on
that vote as if we never voted the vote
the vote motion's already on the floor
we're reconsidering it
now we have to vote yes but but they
were reconsidering a vote that's there i
don't have to make the new motion
because now that means we have not acted
upon that motion that motion is now the
motion on the table the motion on the
table is the bill we don't like we're
right now
we we're starting over this yeah we're
starting our basics
though we had never voted on the
previous otp okay so we never voted on
the previous one i'm not sure that's
what i had heard but
we did but now we're voting on it as if
we didn't vote on it right
so that original bill as amended is now
on the floor yes and we want to vote no
yeah we're not itling we're voting no on
the otp
the vote is on otpa and that is on
what we had done
amendment 0-2-1-0
that is the old amendment okay good
who's going to make that motion
i don't think we need to it's already on
the table it's on the table
okay when you are ready
we do this and we want to vote
no
thank you
you know how late i'm going to be up
tonight trying to figure this out
we've been through this once before as i
recall yes
no
representative mcmahon representative
acton representative gay
representative cushman no representative
folsom no representative kelsey or
kelsey absent
representative king no representative
cofould absent representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative dirk no representative
salloway
representative cannon representative
nader no representative shapiro no
representative woods no representative
merchant no representative pearson no 19
to zip now we can consider
the new amendment
the new amendment you were just handed
20 22 0 409 h representative kenner
would you make a motion please yes also
just to clarify everybody this is just
like we see in the house sessions where
something gets passed it's very
controversial somebody says i move
reconsideration and urge everybody to
vote yes we don't have to repeat the the
uh motion it's already on the table
you're reconsidering so that's why we
didn't need to redo that then so i now
move amendment
4 0 9.
sorry sorry
this is the new
the new amendment that i just handed out
two zero two two zero four zero nine i
moved that amendment
second
i will take soloway's
hand
so this is the amendment
and when you are ready
in just a moment it's on
the amendment 2022-0409
[Music]
to the original house bill 1390 move by
conor represented by soloway
representative leon
yes representative
yes representative acton representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey absent representative king yes
representative cole fault absent
representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway representative cannon
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
19 to zip now before i accept uh the
next vote
representative shapiro
23 people signed up in support of this
and zero against it
thank you so much yes sir hero of
democracy
keep me honest sir please
now we have the possibility of someone
moving
house bill 1390 as just amended by
2022-0409
i see representative canarch's hand up
is there a second
oh you just had one i'm going to give
this one too did i see a handover on
this side of the pool
okay you don't want to second just
anything but this is a good one so um
so the bill as newly amended and
representative canark and gay
and
we know what we're doing here are you
ready i'm ready go
um
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey absent representative king yes
representative cofold absent
representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay
representative snow
representative knurk
shapiro yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes 19-0 and
representative kenner would you write
the committee report please of course
and i presume consent
and what's that consent
done yes do i have it yes yes
no no not been said consent consent on
this bill yes yes but i will i will of
course write the report i i i i i know
it can yeah i will try not to
compulsively find any other errors and
you're writing a blur
yes i mean of course thank you just so
you know that they give the clerks
executive session form for four votes on
a bill
this is the very first time
i've ever filled the whole thing out
the chair wonders should there be any
third-year law students in the room
wasn't that fun there is one look at
that what are the odds of that okay we
are now
uh concluding the executive session on
1390.
yay
well we got it done
i think it's time for a margarita myself
but
i have to drive
depends on how empty my stomach is going
into it
you